and of those uh 43 we've not heard 13
bills those are bills that are currently
scheduled there's six bills left that we
have not scheduled so for a total 49
bills we've had executive sessions on 19
bills that leaves 30 more executive
sessions which we must continue here or
half prior to the
18th recognizing that Tuesday is
election day uh I do not know whether
there I believe they are going to have
hearings here at the capital on that day
I don't have the schedule for next
week's schedule at this point in time so
that I will get that to you as soon as I
can here probably hopefully within uh
sometime
today um it's election day across the
river in Vermont today so I got all the
grandkids at the house so I had my usual
three hours of sleep
and um the um elections coming up for us
on Tuesday for mpal elections um so I'm
going to go ahead and one other thing I
want to note I do have a copy of
hb2 and that's the policy uh statement
which supports hb1 it's not to finance
uh I've been asked by finance division
two to look at the issue of mining
postsecondary
institutions uh here in New Hampshire
Community College and the postsecondary
university system New Hampshire uh I'm
putting together a subcommittee I've
notified those subcommittee members that
are on that committee uh that we will be
doing a r a rush in terms of looking
This research and looking at um and
developing a brief not taking any kind
of position but just identifying the
facts that
exist and and trying to get that
together by the close of this month
um that when they have to start taking
up hb2 in finance so it's a real tight
schedule all the way around those folks
which will be on that myself
representative mopet and representative
um
board on the on the Democratic side we
have representative Miler representative
luno and representative
Ellison you know talked with all six
people that's including myself I talk
myself often um the um issue here is not
a partisan issue of any kind the issue
is our postsecondary education so that's
why I have three members and three
members on there this is a a neutral
committee is trying to look at the
issues associated with combining into
one set of Trustees for the entire
system getting away from the two
trustees system we have now and looking
at all those Associated issues that are
related to combining they're huge it's a
huge issue
so hopefully we can help Finance out
okay I'll take some questions on that a
little later on uh today uh when we have
a few more moments but right now I'd
like to read chairman scpt and get on
with the the bills we have today so as
chair of the House Education committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covid-19 pandemic in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuing to
the executive order
2020-4 this Bo public body is authorized
to meet electronically this is a public
hearing appeals referred to the
education committee executive session on
pending legislation may be held please
note there is no fiscal location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate to
contemporaneously during this meeting
through Zoom electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call 271
3600 or email HCS ledge. state. n. Us in
the event the public is unable to access
the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are in the meeting assisting
us today jennif Kor is our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member State put it
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law Madam
cler representative
cordelli he's testifying upstairs
representative bone here in the
committee room representative Aller here
in the committee room representative
lakus here at home in Hudson sick and my
husband may walk through period
ically
representative here in the committee
room in
healthy representative hson here in the
committee room and
healthy
and here here home alone in the room in
Salsbury represented for home alone in
Cher in my
office representative Lon here in the
committee
room representative s here on the
[Music]
mil here in kuk in and out of thank
you thank you represent L here in
Hopkinson representative sha here in
committee room representative
Corell here in
Manchester representative
Tanner here in h George's Mills sopy
barison uh here conquered alone in my
Bedford representative Le present I am
in Jaffrey and I am home
alone representative
wood here in Center col New Hampshire
with my wife and barking
dog lad I'm present here in yellow
be thank you very much everyone thank
you very much represent sha so with that
folks we're going to go ahead into our
docket for today the first bill is
hb22 relative to school lunch payment
policies I'm also going to be leaving
this session for a few moments here and
representative B is going to be your
interim
chair represent bone you wait
there okay now the first hearing is
on um house
202 to the school lunch payment
policies and the sponsor representative
Horan representative Horan here
representative Horgan is not here at
representative boam this is
representative Mullen and I will be
presenting the bill on his behalf
I have a co-sponsor please go ahead
thank you very much uh good morning uh
to everybody on the committee for the
record I'm Sue Mullen and I represent
Hillsboro district 7 the town of Bedford
this morning I'm here uh to introduce
House Bill 202 because as I mentioned
representative Oregon uh has a conflict
uh they're executing bills in judiciary
this morning and so as a co-sponsor I am
presenting HB to
202 uh 2021s
hb22 actually began its life last
session as House Bill
1127 this committee unanimously passed
it it went through the Full House on a
Voice vote and like so many of our
initiatives last year became a victim of
covid-19 there are two primary
components of House Bill
202 the first is a guarantee that any
student who is unable to pay for their
school lunch is not to be stigmatized by
being offered an alternative uh meal
selection that is unavailable on a daily
basis as part of the regular me meal
program the second component has to do
with communication between school and
Home in that um the bill spells out that
any communication about unpaid balances
needs to take place between school
personnel and the parents and not
involve the kids in the discussion about
whether or not they have a delinquent
account um the meal itself uh has to
follow the guidelines that are outlined
by school nutrition program
standards but uh at the moment those
meals are only offered to Elementary
students I believe that it's
representative Horgan's intent that this
also apply to middle school and high
school students as well last session uh
those of you that were on the Comm
committee remember my discussion about
the cheese sandwich it was a Hallmark
moment for House Education when we
talked about the fact that there are in
it places where kids who don't have
enough money in their account or who are
in AAR are being offered food choices
that cause them either some source of
embarrassment or limit the quality of
the lunch that they're being given or uh
stigmatize them in that when you leave
the lunch line and you've got your
cheese sandwich on your tray and
everybody else is having lasagna with
garlic bread and salad then people know
that your lunch account is uh in the red
because you're leaving the lunch line
with the cheese
sandwich uh regarding the communication
between home and school the bill does
make a provision for kids to be able to
discreetly be given notices uh I.E if a
letter needs to go home then a student
can be asked to tuck the letter into
their backpack and take the letter home
to the parent but what we're trying to
avoid uh with this bill as I mentioned
earlier is the direct conversation you
know in the lunch line with 150 other
kids around about why you don't have
enough money in your lunch account to
pay for your meal that day um I know
that uh Sher white is here this morning
from the Department of Education she is
the administrator of the office of
nutrition programs and services she will
be able to answer any questions that you
may have about specific provisions
we got some email from her I'm hoping
everybody had an opportunity to review
that and at this point I will simply uh
turn myself over to the committee and
answer any questions as I can to the
ability thank you do we have any
questions Mullen yes ma'am I could not
open your email with attachment on it I
tried desperately it sent me to a site
and all that stuff and I couldn't I
couldn't open it um could you just uh
forward it to uh Jennifer cor I would be
happy to do that you're a victim of
high-tech representative
Shaw I never heard of that that format
before I actually went through the uh
legislative uh you know the the program
the Microsoft program that the
legislature uses I should have gone
through my
own Google Drive I I will do that the
next time representative
sha any other questions representative
Woodcock represent Woodcock go ahead
thank you Mr chair representative M just
a quick question if I recall last year
under the parameters of the bill we
talked about the ID and the Stig stigma
that students um were uh not allowed in
the future although it had been
happening in the past to do any school
work help the custodian paint the wall
or is that is that the intent of that ID
sensation in this in this generic part
of you Bill yeah thank you so much
representative Woodcock for bringing
that up um yes that that is still a
component of the bill what it basically
says is that schools are uh should not
put a student in the position of trying
to work off their debt however it does
not prevent students from doing work
around the school if that's part of the
ordinary everyday operational uh sure
way that the school does things so in
other words if in lunchrooms if kids
wipe down tables they can do that as
long as it applies to everybody thank
you so much representative you're
welcome anybody else questions I don't
see anybody okay having seen no further
questions uh we do have a speaker thank
you for your testimony you so much
person who scheduled to speak is Sher
white and she is from the Department of
Education uh she's testifying neutral in
on this B this white from Department of
Deck thank you uh Sher White I am here
in my home in newfields I am in the room
alone um and uh thank you for uh
accepting the uh piece that I did submit
um I just wanted to be sure that
everyone knew that um uh me Molly Kelly
had put forth a very similar bill um
that did uh get approved and is in
RSA it is something that
uh the Department of Education has
already written a technical advisory for
which is listed on our website and is
something that we already trained to to
the
field um one of the uh pieces of that
particular
RSA uh is to ensure that um any meal
that is offered to a child um can be
offered to every single child in the the
school so um for example uh there are
times when a child may actually want a
uh sun butter and jelly sandwich or a
cheese
sandwich and um they uh are now able to
because that has become an alternative
now within the school they are now able
to make that choice so all children can
make the choice to have um you know a
cheese sandwich or a sun butter and
jelly sandwich that was that was uh also
a component of of that particular bill
so I did want to point that out as far
as working off a debt um I'm a little
concerned by hearing that uh because I
do not know of any food service
operations that are requiring children
to work off a debt this is not something
that uh the federal uh component of this
through USD a allows either so I am
concerned about that um and if if that
is happening uh we would need to know
that
immediately um and then uh you know
again the
stigmatization um this is something that
we also uh always watch out for USDA
does not um allow that they have manuals
that we uh train to and provide to the
field um and those manuals um uh do uh
talk about all of the particular things
that uh that were just discussed by the
representative um but I just wanted to
add those things in there because I just
wanted to be sure that you knew that
there was already an RSA in place we
already do a lot of Education and
Training in this area um and you know uh
we are glad to do any more that's needed
um but uh there is that one particular
piece that I just heard that is
concerning to me um because I do not
know of any school that is making a
child work off a
for
repus represent Rec you have a
question yes I was wondering if then you
unnecessary well I I
um to uh say that potentially yes um I
was just looking at it and and um I do
have to say too that uh representative
Horgan had called me
um before he uh wrote it um and before
he presented it to you all um and at
that time I did um tell him that I had
some concerns that it was redundant to
uh the existing um
RSA so um that that was something that I
did um speak with him
about so uh you know I I I think that
that's probably a um a fair question and
yes any further questions I don't see
any further
questions not seeing any thank you Miss
White and
T I don't see anybody with their hand
raised looks like
uh we got to close the session on house
house bill
122 thank you and oh um You probably
wna no I don't know if anybody can hear
me the 67 support 67 support the bill
two opposed two opposed one neutral one
neutral and one testified signed up to
testif one additional testimony
okay session is at 9:45 next next year
9:45 so we have like 20 minutes or so
for a break
[Music]
thank
you okay and since we have people
missing not gonna go
into yeah
okay
[Music]
maybe get back before that okay uh I'll
go um I guess mute the room
yeah
so back then to get from Lincoln to
[Music]
miles
okay okay I have
945 start the hearing on the next
bill
203 esta a committee to study school whe
programs hampire Public Schools Car
School St accept public funds this
represent bill but I assume represent
Mull will
be testifying for the bill that is
absolutely correct representative bone
thank you go ahead please okay thank you
uh good morning again and on behalf of
Representative forgan I'm here to
introduce to you house bill
203 House Bill 203 also had a uh prior
life it was House Bill 1681 in our last
session and uh it had a bit of an
evolutionary arrival to the committee
the last time that representative Horgan
uh presented this bill it it started its
life as a bill to look at whether or not
breakfast should also be offered in
addition to lunch to free and reduced
students in New Hampshire but by the
time we got done discussing the issue we
had more questions than we had
answers uh we had questions about
whether or not all public schools were
utilizing similar resources we had
questions about whether or not um
practices were consistent from school
district to school district we wondered
whether or not there were private
schools out there that had meals
programs that were doing things in a way
that we might learn something
from uh
so the bill ultimately was amended to
move from being a breakfast for free and
reduced students to a study committee of
Food Services practices in New Hampshire
so representative Horgan has resurrected
this bill once again W is requesting
that a study committee be put together
to uh look
at the array of practices that are
taking place in New Hampshire and uh
while he acknowledges that we may not be
able to do do you know a thorough and
comprehensive study in the time allotted
to the bill um the he's hoping that the
committee will prioritize its questions
and be productive
you representative boam are you out
there
I am not hearing
anything is anybody hearing
anything I can hear
you I I heard you representative Cornell
muted
try it now representative bom can you
hear me
yes okay I don't I'm through my computer
now yeah you're gonna have we seem to be
having trouble in the committee room got
it
okay the screen the commit room is
having
mute all right none of us can hear
representative
bam
representative B
echo representative Bo I'm gonna mute
your
device and then someone needs to unmute
up J yep so we lost Conn
C and I I can't tell if we're back or
not I can hear you representative Hobson
I can hear you
okay
yes okay good thank you so represent B
you yes sir okay we yeah we lost the
last few minutes of the testimon
sentences so could you just okay sure um
uh
just in review when we took up this
issue the last time around we ended up
with more questions than
answers um and so representative forgan
uh is hopeful that we will take up the
issue again and that while uh the study
committee may be on a tight timetable uh
he's hoping that they will be able to
prioritize their task in such a way that
we would be able bble to come back with
useful information in the time period
spelled out in the
Bill thank you uh do we have any
questions for repr
Mo I don't see any we can bring in the
next speaker Sherry white again okay so
thank you represent thank you thank you
representative B
so I mean Miss White from the of
uh good morning and and thank you again
I'm Sher white from the Department of
Education um I am in my home in
newfields and I am
alone um all I wanted to do for this one
was just to introduce myself as I
understand there are some new members of
this particular committee um and uh we
uh um you know if if there are any
questions whatsoever um regarding ing uh
School meals the national school lunch
program we would be more than happy to
have there any questions for Miss way I
don't see
any so I'll I'll have one there is do
you know of any problems across the
state with glaring differences between
school lunch programs one district and
another
so the way that a food service program
is
implemented um can be can be
different
um as far as um the uh regulations and
speaking to the
regulations they all have to be in place
um it's just how they Implement their
program in order to meet the uh
regulations so that's that's the biggest
um
difference uh but by and large we see
some consistent pieces as well to the
way that uh food service is implemented
um right now however of course during
covid I'm talking about normal times
during covid we're all over the place um
with implementation and strategies and
and really um uh it that is all based on
the resources that they have to be able
to feed uh the children in the different
ways that Co is requiring that they feed
children at this point in
time rep leus has her hand raised
representative laus um have a question
ahead actually I didn't I must have
accidentally raised sorry anybody else I
don't see anybody else okay thank you so
we're GNA close the hearing on
203 represent lab back again to take
over
the
and are you closing the hearing I'm
closing the
hearing oh yes count the count um if you
can hear me we had two sign in and
support zero oppos one neutral and one
person
so repres German lab I don't know if you
want to like formally tell people to go
ra the refrigerator
get
everybody
okay if you can hear me out there what
we're going to do is we're going to take
at
okay
it
are we live right now we're live good
thank
you
okay okay welcome back everybody uh
we're ready to move forward here with
the the next bill which is
422 relative to the one half credit
required course in the United States in
the Hampshire government and
Civics and we is represent D here I do
him we have anybody from Rockingham it
looks like they're all Rockingham
sponsors
anybody is anybody here familiar with
this
not
oh here we go attendee okay uh
looks
sorry uh Mr Campbell I'm not familiar
with who that is but where did he go I
rep is
person I don't see any representatives
there so it can't be introduced
Mr
Campbell oh I'm sorry Mr Campbell um
could I ask you to hold on a
minute John all Mr Janan our
representative Janan
your your you've been promoted please go
ahead gosh thank you um for the record
I'm representative John janigian
representing Rockingham District 8 which
is Salem New Hampshire um here to
introduce uh HB
422 and um has a um fairly small change
there's already a requirement to
um have a half credit course in Civics
it's already a state requirement and one
of the things that um I've noticed and
in many of my constituents have noticed
and other people I've talked to around
the state is that for some reason a lot
of uh younger people however that may be
defined um uh you know up into maybe 30s
and and so forth don't seem to have a
strong knowledge of um Civics and and
how our surprisingly how our federal
state or local governments work and we
already have this state requirement of a
half crit course um but what 422 does is
it says that half crit course must be a
distinct course because because right
now um it can be satisfied by taking
other courses and you know whether
that's uh that may be causing a problem
so so this bill proposes to make it a uh
Standalone course and for those towns
that I did get some feedback that some
smaller towns uh may be concerned with
having to create course material so
paragraph three starting at line 16 of
the bill um addresses that by saying
that uh the new Hampshire um um
Department of Education will put
together a course outline um using a
committee of New Hampshire Educators to
create a sample curriculum so that
that's pretty much the bill and that's
the um the reason for it and um Mr
Campbell I think will be will be
speaking with some more information
thank
you thank you very much are there any uh
questions for the sponsor of the bill
yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question is
there any reason why you uh require this
in grade 10 and 11 and 12
only um the issue was I think in talking
to people that when you get into that
11th and 12th grade area you are getting
you either are at voting age or you're
close to voting age and the issue is
making sure that you know students take
this um you know as something important
I think if you start possibly at too
young an age I mean this doesn't stop a
school district from teaching it at a
younger age
um this this half credit course is a
high school course but you know if it
want if people in communities want to
teach it sooner that's that's fine but
we just thought that uh I'm open to
suggestions on that but that was the the
thank thank you just one more question
if we already have um a one credit
course and you're going to add this
additional one credit course um to local
graduation
requirements uh does that mean you're
going to reduce the existing history
course from one to a half so we aren't
adding more
requirements um no this this isn't
adding any requirements it's it's
actually one half credit it's a half
credit course in Civics that is
currently required all we're saying is
that half credit course must be a
standalone course now and cannot be
satisfied by taking other courses and
saying okay you've satisfied so there's
no increase in in the number of credits
required only that that half credit
course in Civics be a standalone course
just just final question Mr L if I may
if if this if the requirement of the RSA
already requires one credit in US
history and you're adding a half credit
even though you're D reducing some of
the curricular from the one credit
course that still means it's a one and a
half credits for graduation as I
understand it you not agree I'm not sure
I maybe I'm not explaining it correctly
there there's the requirement is a half
Credit cour in Civics uh must be taken
it can be satisfied by current law by
taking other courses to satisfy it um so
this is so that have Credit in Civics is
still
required um it's just that it's it's got
to be a standalone
course thank you for members of the
committee we do have a technical support
from the Department of Education in the
curriculum area Mr Green is here uh so
if you have some specific questions
regarding that maybe it's perhaps better
that you address them to the department
they may be able to give you a straight
answer in terms of what is being done
done right
now represent Tanner do you have a a
question yes I do and I I don't know if
it'd be better for Mr Green or uh the
representative um it's about the
performance-based assessments that we
have in New Hampshire whether um this
curriculum and and the fact that it's a
course is just seat time with a test and
not uh precludes performance-based
assessments
is that towards the representative or
are you saying maybe we should be asking
the department I think may I think maybe
the department thank you
uh Ellison you have your hand up I do
thank you Mr chair uh and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
given the requirements in the in the
actual
bill is there any difference between
the uh requirements in the bill and
what's already in the RSA which requires
a one credit course in US history in New
Ham us and New Hampshire history and a
half Credit in US New Hampshire
Civics
um the I think the the the issue is the
the history courses I think the problem
is resulting and and you know I think
when Mr Campbell speaks he can speak
more um accurately about this but the
problem seems to be that that half
credit course is being sat in Civics is
being satisfied through the history
courses but perhaps not adequately
because we do see so many young people
who don't seem to have a strong
understanding in in federal state and
local government operations so that
that's the again that's the impetus to
this thank you thank you at this time
I'm gonna uh look next to have Mr Green
come on and from the Department of
Education and I I believe many of your
questions can be directed to
him uh Mr Green are you there he's here
yeah I am good morning good morning how
can you help
us sure so just to provide a little bit
of clarification because it sounded like
there was a couple of questions around
the credit requirements So currently
there is a one full credit requirement
in the US American history
and a half credit requirement in Civics
those are both required for graduation
currently under New Hampshire state law
so the changes in this bill would not
change graduation requirements in any
way as a department sees it um because
there's already a one and a half credit
requirement so the bill appears to be
just clarifying some of the language
around that um it's not adding any
additional graduation requirements onto
what we currently
require um the way that curriculum works
with with required graduation courses is
a school district generally determines
what are the specific competencies based
on the content that has been required
from the Department of Education so in
this case the half credit course in
Civics has some pretty specific uh
components to the curriculum that are
already outlined in 18911 so school
districts would be required to have that
within their half credit course in
Civics um I think what the
representative is referring to is
sometimes school districts will take
that Civics course and they'll embed
that into a larger course that might be
a full credit and so the half credit
component of civics is being met by a
student who's taking a full credit
course that includes content going
Beyond just the minimum Civics
requirements so my understanding is that
the new language in this bill would
require that half credit Civics course
to be its own Standalone course and not
to be embedded within a larger course is
representative Jen do you have a
response to that yes I I would agree
with
what Mr Green just
said then Mr Green can you please
explain to us what type of forces are
in um I think it would depend on the
school district itself I think it's a
small percentage of districts that are
embeding it in a larger course uh the
majority of school districts offer
Civics as a standalone half credit
course right now um I have seen some
school districts embedded along with an
English course and so they include um a
broader look at Humanities as well so
the Civics might be embedded in there
along with English and Ela competencies
and again that takes a course from being
a half credit to a full credit course um
because they're not only just doing the
Civics pieces but they're also looking
at broader Humanities topics within the
course it's really District specific um
and to be honest I couldn't tell you off
the top of my head um a district that is
doing that currently but you know
there's nothing in the rules right now
that precludes a district from doing
that represent Tanner did you have a
Department yeah my um thank you chairman
lad my question was about the
performance-based assessments where if
this if the state department writing uh
curriculum um are they going to is there
going to be
some
um at least some effort to include
performance-based assessments where
students actually use and apply the the
uh knowledge that they learn um rather
test yes so uh any kind of technical
assistance that we provide to districts
from a a curriculum and instruction
perspective um includes a focus on
Competency Based education and
performance-based assessments um we've
really moved in that direction as a
state um and I think we've done so in a
really Innovative way over the last 10
years um our focus in the state really
is on encouraging students to attain
Mastery of the competencies in a course
through a variety of Assessments um that
includes paper and pencil based tests
but it also includes Hands-On learning
it includes performance-based tasks and
assessments um because we've seen that
that's really the best way to get at
understanding the broad knowledge that
students possess within a particular
course I will say though anytime the
department engages in work that's
specific to curriculum and instruction
it's generally done as a way of
providing guidance towards districts
it's a way of providing assistance to
districts but curriculum and instruction
really Falls within the realm and
purview of the local school board and so
we can Pro provide documents we can
provide guidance um but often times that
has to be adopted by the local school
board as well because curriculum
Authority Ellison is your hand up for
for yes it is yes it is uh thank you Mr
chairman and Nate thanks for taking my
question I just want to be be sure I'm
clear on the description that you gave
which I think was that all the elements
of requirements of a Civics course even
if they're put into a larger course have
fulfilled yes that is correct so under
the current law that we have if you
embed a Civics course in a larger course
it still has to have all of the required
elements of a course even if it was
taught as a standalone course those
competencies have to be the
you Mr Green I got a question sort of a
followup to represent woodcock's
question that was brought up earlier the
legislation says this one half credit
course shall be a distinct course
separate from other history courses and
required in the Junior and Senior year
so do we have schools out there right
now that are teaching Civics in the
ninth and the 10th grade and but this
says it's going to have to be down in
the 11th or 12th grade as it's
written yes we do have schools that
teach Civics across 9 through 12 um so
there are some schools that are offering
it to freshmen um there's some students
who take it in their 10th grade year
oftentimes a student that might take it
in their senior year has done so because
there were issues in their schedule in
their n9th or 10th or 11th grade year
where they were trying to take other
courses and it just didn't fit within
their schedule and it gets pushed
towards their senior year um but right
now we don't have a requirement on the
grade level and so it varies widely
across the St State thank you are there
further questions of the department
Mullen
has thank you very much Mr chair um
thank you Mr Green for taking my
question uh when you talk about these
courses that have Civics embedded within
them uh would an AP class or uh an IB
class be examples of a course that might
have the Civics competencies embedded in
existing one credit
courses they could but that's generally
not the case because the Civics courses
are required to have a focus not just on
us Civics and um citizenship but as well
as New Hampshire and AP and IB courses
tend not to have a New Hampshire
specific Focus so if a teacher were to
embed Civics into a course like that
they would have to go beyond the
traditional AP curriculum to ensure that
there is a New Hampshire Focus as well
well being taught in that course right
okay thank you very
[Music]
much thank you very much are there we
have some other folks that are waiting
to testify are there any more questions
of the
department Mr Green are you gonna hang
loose here throughout this
discussion I will yeah
yes okay so we'd like to have next uh
Bernard
Campbell okay I just promoted um Mr
please thank you uh thank you very much
um Mr chairman honorable members of the
uh education committee uh my name is
Bernie Campbell and I'm a social studies
teacher at Salem High School uh
representative jenan recently reached
out to one of my colleagues uh seeking
input on this proposed bill and she
graciously included me on that
conversation uh as this is something
that I have been very passionate about
over the last several years uh I believe
that it's very important that Civics
education be given a separate emphasis
within the curriculum uh in many
districts um Civics is included as a
component of an American history class
well this might seem to be a natural fit
the reality is that combining these two
requirements is not as efficient as one
might think it what changes both
subjects Civics is only covered in the
most basic sense while history content
is squeezed to make room for civics
requiring Civics as a separate class
will free up space within history
classes as well as giving more space to
take a longer look at Civics instruction
to include time for more practical
Hands-On activities like mock
legislatures mood courts and
participatory experiences like observing
local government in action while it's
true that I would say that most New
Hampshire High School students can
indeed name their governor and their
full Congressional
delegations uh few could name more than
a handful of their own state
representatives or members of their
local city council or select boards few
would even be aware of the role of other
local boards such as budget committees
or land use boards which arguably have
an even greater direct impact on their
lives than their representatives in
Washington uh it was my hope that this
bill would explicitly require the class
in the senior year it's my belief that
this class is most impactful the closer
students are to turning 18 and obtaining
their full rights I understand that uh
representative and his fellow sponsors
felt that giving the flexibility to
offer in the junior year might Aid uh
school districts and I respect that
offering any earlier than that is not in
my experience as useful for sophomores
students who are mainly 15 and 16 years
old these concepts are still too
abstract too far away to concern them
it's a class that's more effective for
the older grades who are about to take
their first steps into adulthood there's
no doubt in my mind that this bill would
improve the Civics education of all
students exiting New Hampshire's high
schools I believe very strongly that the
events of the last few years have proven
that more needs to be done to educate
students on the functions of government
so they're better prepared to be
responsible informed citizens when they
turn 18 thank you for your time ladies
and gentlemen and I hope you will
recommend passage of this Bill thank you
very much are there questions for Mr
Campbell yes represent Woodcock thank
you representative lad Mr Campbell just
a question I hear your your comments
about the the necessity of changing the
curricula have you brought that to your
local school board and asked them to do
it um we've had some conversations
around adjusting our uh curriculum uh
those conversations have not yet proven
fruitful thank you thank you Mr lad are
there further
questions oh yeah repr bone thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question in small school
districts it's sometimes impossible
for students especially up at the top
level to fit in all the re the classes
that they need and by requiring that
don't you think that requiring this in
just the last two years of high school
will put a problem on those students
coures thank you uh representative I to
your point I think that there's enough
flexibility in scheduling to allow this
uh even in within smaller school
districts uh half credit class is um you
know in a block schedule it's only 45
days in a uh in a regular schedule it's
only 9
so it's only a halfe course in a in a
regular schedule course or it's only a
45-day class in a block schedule I I
don't necessarily see that that's an
obstacle um even in a smaller School
District further questions thank you
very much Mr C thank you
sir okay uh we were supposed to have
Carl lad speak I don't see him from the
New Hampshire uh administrators
Association
um I do
see and Patrice Myers I don't see her
either Jerry Jerry okay so maybe Mr F
Jerry is the school Minister
okay Mr F you've been promoted go ahead
and speak please yes thank you very much
uh I was unclear that that
uh Dr Lad had registered to speak so I
wasn't prepared for an eloquent speech
as he might have been I believe he's
sitting in Senate Ed right now so but I
I do want to uh Echo uh representative
bom's uh concern about the impact on
smaller school districts uh we do feel
that this um does pose a a financial
obligation uh and also might impact
students ability to choose other courses
because districts would be required to
have certain sections of specific
specifically Civics education uh which
most do anyway um but also some of the
creative approaches to Humanities and uh
as uh Nate green pointed out those
components of civics education still
have to be included in the humanities
course or in the United States history
version so we do feel that this um bill
is duplicative
and a financial obligation uh and is
unnecessary and as a result would
request uh respectfully request in
expedient to legislate for
this okay uh rep Tanner are there
further
questions rep Tanner has hand rep Tanner
do you have your hand up yes I
do um and thank you Mr chair for
recognizing me uh and Mr Fu um would
having an extra requirement like this in
the Junior and Senior year interfere
with people uh students that are going
to uh
CTE thank you for the thank you for the
question representative Tanner um and
that is a great question because yes
every every restriction that you put on
um the schedule of a junior or senior um
in high school does impact other pieces
of their selection process and CTE could
certainly be impacted um for a halfe
course uh you know I look at the
experience with with kirar sending
students to conquered um for the CTE
programs in conquered when they do that
they miss travel time to get to and from
conquered and so the more restrictions
you put on the Junior and Senior year um
the the more you impact a student
selection process so thank you for that
for that great question and and just as
a former social studies teacher uh you
must understand that I am all for Civics
education yay Bravo model un do it all
but we we have to be judicious in how we
invest our district resources and be
careful not to impose restrictions on
student selections thank you thank you
re L thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Fu for taking the question um I'm
just it's just a followup here on what
I've been hearing from both yourself and
I think from uh Mr Green from the
Department of Ed think you both confirm
for me did you both say that basically
most or the vast majority of school
districts are already offering this as a
standalone
course thank you for the question I
would defer to uh Nate green for the
specific of that answer it would be my
impression based on my knowledge of
being involved in um a number of school
districts throughout my 45y year career
that the answer would be yes that um the
the course is already included in uh the
program of studies in in all high
schools in the state in one fashion or
another thank
you further questions I did promote Mr
Green if you wanted to answer but I'm
not sure is Diana Benton here yes can
sure good morning Miss Fenton welcome to
education can you can you hear us Diana
y
there muted
yes morning here got a question for you
attorney Fon um where school districts
have Authority for instruction and
curriculum is this legislation going to
undermine local control or local school
board control their instruction and
their
curriculum
oh wow that's not a loaded question at
all
um I I don't know if I can opine on
whether or not it would undermine it I I
think you have to look at it in totality
with the other requirements that are
imposed on a school district I don't
think I'm in a position to say whether
or not it would undermine local control
um I think you've heard from the
representative from doe to establish how
school districts are already structured
and how they're dealing with this
requirement already um and and I I don't
think I can go much further than than
that in my opinion okay thank you are
there other questions of attorney
F right thank you um who's next uh I
speakers El nobody nobody else said are
there any comments from members of the
committee we are a few minutes away from
ending this but it looks like we're
finished
here thank you very much uh everybody so
with that uh we're going to conclude uh
this bill uh which is 422 deals with the
requirement of United States and and man
Hampshire government and
Civics uh how many people do we have
that signed up we have um 13 in support
13 in support four opposed four opposed
two neutral two neutral and three
scheduled to testify one was not here
and we had two that uh
testify along with support from the
much I'll
back yeah
Wednesday
yeah
today
want
do we could uh hey Rick yeah keep
online chair
yeah yeah just a just a quick question
for you at the at the top of when we got
19 um let me get my paper I think that's
what I said yeah I think that's what
said I'm I'm showing that too so um so I
just want to make sure that and it looks
like we've got one two after this week I
think I'm showing one two three four
eight bills still for or no seven bills
still for hearings see I came down with
six so
okay and what I also called arette
following when I went out there's a
possibility you may see that dat of the
right that won't be confirmed till late
this
afternoon 30 odd Z session
still so a lot of work ahead of us right
right and there there was one bill 521
that was vacated to finance yes that's
correct
okay all right so
um
yeah I'll I'll send you the list of the
seven bills I think we haven't heard or
I'll I'll try
to figure out what's going on there you
have see the bills that I have we
haven't done as far as hearings 136 just
write 136
409 and 464 those the six that I have
152 I'm that also okay we're showing
that also so I missed that one last
night
okay all right I think we're on the same
page thank you great thanks Rick for
bringing that
up
okay we're going to go ahead our our
clerk is
back and we're ready to go ahead with
319 this is an act requiring students in
the university and Community College
systems of New Hampshire to pass the
United States citizenship and
Immigration Services Civics
naturalization
test and representa M you are the prime
spots on that is that correct that's
correct are you gonna be introducing it
that's the plan that's the plan you have
the floor thank you Mr sh uh uh for the
record I am representative Mike Moffett
of marac County District 9 which
includes the wonderful towns of
canterberry in Lin uh and I also want to
welcome those anyone who might be
watching from home to education
committee to this hearing on a bill that
actually focuses on education and
knowledge and
citizenship uh HB 319 simply asked that
our Granite State college and university
public college and university graduates
demonstrated a basic Proficiency in
Civics fundamentals uh by simply passing
the natural ation exam that we require
new citizens to study uh it's simple
it's short and it's I think it is sweet
uh of course this proposed measure
raises questions as any bill should it's
why we're here so let me try to address
them quickly up front uh I have three of
them here number one is this assessment
really needed and our my answer is
absolutely data abounds that demonstrate
the the rful lack of knowledge that our
college graduates have in the way of
civics and history uh just Google the
topic and you'll be probably horrified
uh that is if you think college
graduates should know something about
government if they're going to be good
citizens the recent National survey one
of here's one of many many examples um a
recent National survey conducted by the
American Council of trustees and alumni
it's called America's knowledge crisis a
survey on Civic
literacy uh the survey found shortfalls
in Americans knowledge of history and
how our country
operates a poll of with thousand people
mostly college graduates found that 63%
of respondents did not know the term
Links of US senators and and
representatives 20% in that survey
thought that Alexandria acasio Cortez
offed the New Deal no that was Franklin
Rosevelt uh maybe they thinking of the
green New Deal uh very
different uh I I was a college professor
for many years and I'd often throw in a
bonus extra credit Civics question at
the end of quizer exam students actually
look forward to these extra credit
questions there was no
penalty uh questions like who is your
Congress person many just did not know
these are college students uh who is on
the $10 bill uh most would get that wwn
I know some of you watching from home
are thinking who is on a $10 bill and
I'm not going to tell you uh if you look
it up you'll remember it that's uh a
little pedagogic thing there uh where
was the tree of
parasite some St St that WR who's Buri
in Grant's Tom how get answers like the
Unknown Soldier and the answer of course
is President Grant so anyway is the
Civics exam needed emphatically
yes number two uh should the legislature
should we be dictating specific academic
measures on a postsecondary level and uh
I agree uh that we should not for the
most part again it's someone who has
worked and taught of the University
system for seven years and then the
community Crow system for for 20 years I
I would bristle uh at having curriculum
imposed or requirement impos uh if you
think hurting legislators is like
hurting C then uh some you know
faculties are very similar uh they don't
want generally to have requirements
impos so I get that I I am a legislator
I am a professor or academic but I and
many others believe that legislators
parents and New Hampshire citizens have
some basic Universal expectations as to
what an educated college graduate should
know and we think that such a graduate
should be able to read WR speak English
at a certain level of proficiency and we
also think secondarily that a graduate
should have some minimal level of
knowledge of history and government in
order to be an Engaged citizen so
ignoring those two areas means that we
are not doing our jobs we meaning uh
legislators uh now English composition
is a fairly Universal requirement that's
covered fairly well civix is not and we
think it should be
and if we as American citizen
legislators tolerate excuse or enable
ignorance in such an important area then
then bad on
us and this is not an extreme radical
proposal there are numerous examples of
this working in other
states uh due to our wonderful federal
system of
government uh and if you don't
understand the federal system that I
refer to then you should probably
support the civix requirement uh for
example the Florida Board of Education
recently put in a college Civics
requirement Missouri uh passed into law
the same statute that we're looking at
here which requires scoring a 70 or
better on the
Naturalization exam so yes many of us
feel it's not only appropriate but
necessary for the legislature for this
committee to codify expectations here I
we think it's our duty our job and
number three uh is this an unfed
unfunded
mandate uh this comes up often
appropriately so want to make the case
that much of what our legislature passes
involves some sort of unfunded Mandate
of sorts uh so sometimes we do need to
monetize things that's why we have
occasional fiscal notes uh but requiring
this modest assessment really shouldn't
be that taxing quote unquote air quotes
taxing uh as our 44th President like to
say and I know you all know who our 44th
president was uh yes we can yes we can
an inspiring motto much more inspiring
than no we can't no we can't so it's
been said before be said again that if
we ask for this ass assessment we have
send Oney the call system so they can
hire more people to implement it and I
say
really I've also worked as a sports
information director public information
officer and almost every day my office
receive requests for information
statistic interviews data photos You
Name It We regularly get requests for
reports or forms to fill out we just did
it it was our job and colleges have
regist offices and counseling offices
and academic advising officers and all
kinds of services in place to document
and certify transcripts and and uh
assist students in their Journeys so the
infrastructure is in place interns could
help so the the notion that this is a a
major crossly requirement uh we
reject so um and it's also important to
point out uh to finish this up that last
week uh the New Hampshire House of
Representatives overwhelmingly passed HB
320 a similar measure that simply
required that New Hampshire High School
students uh also score a 70 or better in
the citizenship test as a graduation
requirement uh the measure passed our
body by almost 70 votes with SP
sponsorship and support from both
parties so we're we're optimistic that
this measure will also be approved by
the upper body and signed into law by
the governor and if anyone at home does
not know what I mean by the upper body
then well you maybe should have taken
zimic so the point here is that if HB
320 becomes LW then that covers the
college
requirement that this measure H be 319
the first so uh hopefully many of sub
320 makes it all the way to becoming WR
and then eventually that would take care
of this requirement for future college
students from New
Hampshire um to uh to
satisfy and uh as to the implementation
of the exam on campuses I've taught uh
using the Blackboard platform nhti used
a different platform teaching in
University system an online version is
very easy and simple to set up and to
administer students could take it at
their convenience in their
pajamas uh if they so desire um
traditional paper exams of course would
be an option that's kind of up to the uh
institutions so anyway to conclude uh I
I I want to share some of the feedback
we received after passing HB 320 the
iceo
requirement uh which some of you may
have seen comments like great idea
overdue it's about time
yes way to go and God bless you so we
got some good feedback from that PE
people parents want these Civics
measures they want these both those to
move forward students maybe not so much
right now but uh they'll they'll thank
us later so say say no we can I say yes
we can and I hope that we'll vote Yes we
can and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
questions for represent
M oh yes
represent thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking the
question um so you say there's no
additional requirement or cost but how
would this test be delivered well what
is your expectation here and how this
would be done is it done in specific
courses many universities don't require
necessarily any particular history
requirement or if they
do it could be European history or world
history um so where do you expect this
this test to be delivered at no cost and
at no um at no cost at all whether it be
Financial cost or time taken up in other
classes in a university setting thank
you uh show up of my thanks for the
question I I I thought I kind of just
spoke that uh to I don't want to be too
prescriptive in telling any institution
precisely how to uh satisfy a
requirement but as I said earlier uh
from my own experience to create an
assessment and make it available online
and I specifically mentioned the
Blackboard capability and uh and I also
mentioned a different platform I used
the university system these as I said
these exams can be uh created online
students would take it with a with a
passcode uh if they're convenience so uh
so for student was in college for two
three four years to uh at one point
uh make some time to take this online I
think would be very very simple and easy
thank you very followup Mr chairman
followup so I mean in this sort of
system you're proposing let's say a
Blackboard exam or an online exam that's
available at any time I mean I can go
online now I have gone online and I I've
looked up the exam I have copies of the
questions I also have all the answers so
I'm not quite sure what you expect to
accomplish here in terms of actual F
knowledge if the student can take it
online and simply have next to them the
list of questions and the list of
answers sure thank you that's a good
question and uh I go back to the the
many many assessments uh exercises uh
Etc that I've required students to do
online and and uh it's it's always been
a concern about online type of exams and
there there are ways to provide some
security uh with in administering those
in terms of uh you know having the
material in front of them uh that's
that's a reality and and the fact of the
matter is that if uh if the student
takes the 128 question assessment uh
however they answer the questions
whether they study ahead of time or they
use notes with them uh just the fact
that they have to read and look at 128
relevant useful uh screen
history and civics government questions
uh is only a plus so this material would
inevitably wash over anyone who takes
the exam and uh by osmosis if nothing
else uh they would become better
informed more knowledgeable and and
smarter final question Mr chair one more
question yes okay thank you so um um did
I hear correctly representative that um
uh New Hampshire students who if if the
other bill is signed into law that New
Hampshire students who would take the uh
exam uh in high school uh that would
cover for them in college or in
University in the public system if I
heard that correctly well I guess my
question is one did I hear that
correctly and second if that is so then
really is this exam then at the
University level aimed at transfer
students from out of state and
international students because that
would be the only other people who would
who would be subject to it thank you
sure thank you uh
good question uh certainly if uh HP 320
moves continues to move forward and it
becomes a high school requirement then
uh it would be redundant for them to
take the exact same exam so it' be like
an AP uh type situation where or running
stock type situation where a student
satisfies this requirement in high
school uh just very easily is uh added
to their colge transcript so this uh of
course initially should 39 HB 319 move
forward then you know current colge
students would need to uh to take the
exam uh and yes good good question uh
out of Staters uh particularly
University system the community college
system is 90 95% of Hampshire uh
students uh University system has a much
higher percentage of out of Staters and
uh they would have to take this if this
moves forward they have to take this to
satisfy uh University system
requirements which we think is good you
know they would uh know more document
that they've learned some history C some
government before they graduate from
University thank you thank you uh
representa wock thank you representative
repres M thank you for taking my
question I may have missed this I was I
was just a question about the finances I
know you said there wasn't much to it um
if a college requires this can they
course thank you it's it's not a course
it's a just a an assessment it's uh for
example when I started college I had to
take a uh math proficiency and an
English comp proficiency uh test and if
I didn't do well enough on those exams I
would have to take college math or
college uh English
uh I not you need know this I did pass
those exams this a similar type thing
colleges oftentimes have uh requirements
or assessments of different sorts
surveys or whatever uh to help them uh
for example at NTI we had every student
uh take a math test so that we could
determine which Math course would they
be best suited for so uh yeah this type
of assessment is uh is is really fairly
routine and uh postsecondary
institutions followup Mr chair yes thank
you representa m i I understand the
college piece I was there for 12 years
but I also understand that every time
the college has an opportunity to charge
a student for a activity they typically
do because they're in the business of
making money or staying afloat so a
mathematical assessment exam where they
going to be placed do they need to take
an addition College course which they
have to pay for all I'm saying is is
there going to be any requirement or
anything you Bill that would prohibit a
college or from charging any fee to the
student I just see this as a as a money
maker for colleges so is there anything
thing to prohibit that thank you obser
it's very interesting never thought of
that uh that Financial component is in
terms of
charging uh the wheels are turning a
little bit I suppose if an inst
institution wanted to uh make it
available in some fashion to uh even non
students to come in and take it and pay
money to uh to take this exam uh that's
something maybe they locally could
decide hadn't thought about that but
that's that's an interesting thought but
b line is uh I I certainly would not
anticipate any charge for the students
to have to take the required assessment
it would be free BAS
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative representa M thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question um so just clear up
for me if you will representative
Moffett would you use this exam as an
admission requirement
in thank you well no no uh don't
Envision this as an admission
requirement at all uh it would just be
uh a graduation requirement that could
be checked off at some point uh probably
at the students convenience if if it if
the institution opts to make it
available
online a followup Please Mr chair thank
you um so how thank you representative
for for clearing that up how would uh
what kind of Provisions would you make
for international students would they be
required to pass this exam in the same
way that you would expect that if I went
to the University of Rome that I would
be able to pass an exam on Italian
government thank
you very interesting question and and uh
again it's it's graduation requirement
uh for example as I mentioned English
composition is a fairly Universal
postsecondary requirement so in most
every
nowadays most every person in your
institution has an
ESL office or ESL
coordinator so yes if we expect our
graduates to speak and right at a
certain level of English uh wherever
they come from uh this would just kind
of go hand in hand with that I mean if
they can't speak or read English then
they yes they'd have trouble with this
exam but I I think that we expect our
way the universal requirement of English
composition is it is an expectation that
students uh wherever they come from have
a a certain level of English
proficiency thank you very much uh not
see any more hands for represent we do
have yes thank you thanks than my
question um we just went through um
passing the bill in a house for high
school at 70 score level uh College
shouldn't we bump that up to 80 perhaps
it's the higher standard for
college uh thank you s if the folks in
home me near his question he thought
that perhaps 70 is too forgiving and we
should have a higher standard for
college students uh I understand your
thinking I kind of support that but uh
to keep things consistent and simple uh
if we ask high school students to get a
70 and if they're going to uh
theoretically use the same exam to
satisfy a college
requirement uh if we did that then they
might get a 70 in high school and then
they have to take it again to get an 80
in college so to keep it simple and
sweet we're just keeping it at 70 at uh
a proposal for both both
levels thank you very much uh no more
questions we have represent or not
represent Mr CR from the University
system he on De y he he's been promoted
go ahead Mr cron and welcome to any uh
educ
than you representative uh good morning
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you uh for the opportunity to
speak with you this morning for the
record my name is Tom Cronin I'm the
director of government relations for the
University system of New Hampshire uh i'
just like to start with a thanks to
representative Moffett uh for his
Outreach on this bill uh he's been in
touch a little bit over the last couple
of days just to sort of tell us a little
bit more about his motivation and and
how he's trying to to see this through
so we certainly appreciate uh that
Outreach um we also share sort of his
concern for these issues and some of the
sponsors concerns uh we we definitely
believe it is part of our responsibility
to help prepare our students to be
engaged and informed Civic participants
um so for those reasons we're we're
neutral on the bill but we did want to
speak today to a number of concerns with
the drafting that we hope the committee
could consider going forward um so if I
can Mr chairman I'll just I'll just run
through those quickly so to begin and a
number of these have been sort of uh
discussed by the committee in questions
so far but to begin the bill puts the
onus on students to show proof of having
passed uh the citizenship and
Immigration Services test with a score
of 70 or better so certainly uh our
institutions appreciate that the bill
does not seem to create a new
administrative burden for the
institutions to oversee the test but the
bill is pretty vague and these questions
sort of raise those questions as to what
is required of the institution so for us
I think a question would be what
constitutes proof of having passed the
test who is that proof supposed to be
reported to uh what kind of record
keeping would be required um so there's
conversation so far about including
these on transcripts nothing in the bill
seems to put a requirement on
institutions to do any of this work um
second the Bill's requirements for
passing the test are a little bit
unclear um so I had to do a little bit
of research on the the test myself and
preparing for the hearing so our
understanding is the 2020 immigration
test asks citizenship applicants
randomly 20 out of the 128 possible
questions applicants need to answer 12
of those correctly which is a 60% so is
the expectation that students would need
to answer 14 out of 20 random questions
uh or are they expected to answer 90 out
of the full 128 question test if I did
my math right on that um so it's it's
not clear to us what test what test
students are supposed to take or how
it's supposed to be uh administered um
as I think folks know this test is
designed to be given orally and under
different requirements dur in the
naturalization process um some quick
Googling I was able to find a place to
take practice 20 question exams but I
don't I could not easily locate uh how
to take the full 128 question exam as I
think representative lay noted there is
however very easily accessible uh the
full 128 questions with the answers
right next to them um a date requirement
the bill sets this new requirement for
students admitted or transferring to the
institutions on or after January 1:22 so
so that's just an that's a bit of an
awkward date for academic years as
you're all well aware so for some number
of years this language is going to
result in some students in different
graduating years needing to take the
test While others won't just because of
whether or not they transferred into or
uh if when they started at the
University uh similarly uh as you're all
aware the house recently passed House
Bill 320 um so thank you we it was
helpful to hear a little bit that it
would effectively create I guess an opt
out for New Hampshire students that have
passed that test um there is a little
bit I think of confusion about again how
we record keep that do we just do
students just need to to tell us that
they passed the test in high school um
and that's sufficient proof similarly uh
the sponsor noted a couple other states
that have similar tests so our students
from and I forget the examples he gave
but our students from those States able
to to Simply opt out and again this is
obviously a small population but for
naturalized citizens who have actually
taken the test are they able to opt out
um and finally this is a little
bit again more of a technical question
but the bill is very specific and
requiring students to pass the 2020
version of the test uh as you may know
this 202 2020 test uh was an update by
the Trump Administration that was
finalized in November of 2020 um I
believe it was just last week or the
week before the Biden Administration
announced their intention to do away
with that update and uh effective April
19th of 21
citizenship and immigration services
will only be offering the 2008 test so
again given the specificity of the
proposal it's unclear how students are
going to meet the 2020 requirement if
that test is no longer accessible
through citizenship and immigration and
similarly if there are future updates to
the test uh the legislation as written
would seem to sort of Hold Us in a
moment in time um that may or may not be
again accessible or doable uh should
there be changes and then lastly I just
you know just want to point out you know
on a a fundamental level um when the
legislature established the university
system in 1981 um the general court
wrote the general court has delegated
broad authority to the Board of Trustees
who shall be responsible for managing
the university system in a manner which
promotes academic excellence and serves
the educational needs of the people of
New Hampshire so as you can imagine our
board our administrative leadership our
faculty take this responsibility
seriously um and I would just note that
nowhere else to my knowledge in RSA 187
has the legislature seen fit to
establish specific graduation
requirements so this would be kind of a
Step Beyond what is what the legislature
has typically done uh in regard to kind
of their oversight of the University
system um so I think with that I'll stop
and I would of course be happy to to
take any questions thank you very much
Mr Cronin uh repr hops you have a
question yes thank you for taking my
question and thank you Mr Cronin I was
wondering if you had sent this testimony
into our emails I had not yet I will as
soon as we wrap up or as soon as I wrap
up that would be helpful thank
you questions from representative
whitcock thank you chairman Le thank you
Mr cor for taking my question going back
to the uh possible fee attachment if the
university system was required to
administer this test track this test put
on the transcripts and show somehow that
it was passed or not passed or retaken
would there would you believe typically
there'd be an administrative fee for
that or a course credit fee for that
yeah I would I don't think so I
it's it would it would really all depend
on again there there were too many
questions for us to really there was no
fiscal note attached to this so we
haven't kind of dived into that piece of
it and again the questions I raised are
questions we'd have on how we would
administer this um I I think I'd want to
say no to that answer but I don't know
until we kind of a better understanding
of what would be expected uh from the
administrative administrative side thank
you Mr croner thank you Mr chair thank
you there further questions we do have
the Community colle system also waiting
y so we'll go ahead thank you very much
all
sh H yep we have Shannon Reed and I
don't know if uh representative Moffett
had a
question sure M I didn't know if you
wanted me to respond to some M quickly
respond to some of Mr cronin's questions
or not but no because you presenting and
you can't respond as a Committee Member
I didn't know if you had a question okay
goad go ahead Shannon Reed okay thank
you can everybody hear me yes we can
okay great thanks um my name is Shannon
Reed I am director of government Affairs
for the community college system of New
Hampshire I'd like to thank you all for
the opportunity to testify and just a
warning my my home is being buffeted I
feel like I might end up in Oz at some
point with the wind and my power has
been flickering so if I disappear it's
it's because of that and not anything
else
um so the sign-in sheet for remote
testimony only offers the options of
support oppose or neutral and really
none of these exactly fits my testimony
I come with questions and a few concerns
uh to share with the committee first I
would I would like to say that ccsnh
believes strongly that knowledge of
civics is important to the richness and
success of our democracy we cultivate
that with opportunities for students to
take courses see candidates hear
speakers and participate in a variety of
events and activities
academically while specific offerings
vary across our seven colleges we have a
general outcome expectation for students
to acquire Knowledge and Skills to
function effectively as informed
citizens students can meet this outcome
by completing general education courses
or major courses U and specifics are
going to differ by college and program
but it's likely that students in an
associate degree program will take one
or more courses such as American
government US History state and local
government inter to political science
American constitutional history that
that type of thing um certain majors
will focus on this curriculum while for
others they would come in as
electives so in approaching this bill we
have a few questions to raise that we
hope the committee will explore or the
sponsor uh perhaps clarify and um my
comments today are really designed to
help us us and the committee arrive at a
full understanding of not just the
intent of this bill but also its
implications and we do appreciate the
sponsors having connected with us prior
to the hearing um to talk about several
of these concerns I will try not to be
redundant because some of these
questions have already been raised and
discussed um but but first we have also
assumed that nothing in this Bill calls
upon the colleges to administer this
test but but only obligates students to
demonstrate having passed it as
specified we had the same questions
about how individuals will access the
test and validate having passed and the
sponsor addressed that um but I think
there are probably still some question
questions connected with those Logistics
second and this this is more a question
for I think the community colleges than
the university system but to what types
of programs would this requirement apply
for for example we offer associate
degree programs which are typically
completed in two years of full-time
study or longer if a student is going
part-time and two-thirds of our students
do go part-time um but we also offer
short-term programs certificates boot
camps uh industry certification programs
um the bill doesn't specify but our one
question is um to to what type of
programs um with this requirement for
having pass this test apply um third the
sponsor reference Tas Bill 320 which
creates that high school requirement um
and suggested that that might ease the
burden on on college students then
making that transition from high school
to College New Hampshire nearly half of
our students are overage 25 with a
significant proportion being in their
30s or or more so we would just note
that the high school requirement
wouldn't position those students in the
same way as it would a student who just
graduated from a New Hampshire High
School my fourth question relates to
licensing and this may require
information from the office of
professional lenser uh and that and that
is would there be an impact for students
who have otherwise completed a program
and would sit for a licensing exam to
enter a profession if they haven't met
this requirement and therefore haven't
technically graduated I don't know if
this would be an issue frankly but it
came up in our in our internal
conversations about the bill and it
seemed worth looking into um that would
certainly be a concern for us since one
of our priorities is graduating students
who can enter professions in their
communities we also had questions about
whether this bill could create
accreditation issues for our colleges in
that it it may be seen as creating some
kind of a curricular requirement we went
right to the source for that and shared
the language with the New England
Commission on higher education
Nei which I believe is here today to
testify to those specific points that
they know far more about that than I do
and I'll just wrap up with two
additional
considerations um first as I mentioned
earlier two-thirds of our students are
part-time completing a program is
typically one of many responsibilities
that a community college student is
juggling which may include full-time or
part-time work parenting Etc as I said
we certainly believe that knowledge of
civics is important to the richness and
success of our democracy the fact is
though that adding this requirement
could be a barrier to college completion
we do a lot at our colleges to to try
lower barriers I understand the
sponsor's emphasis on Civics education
and certainly share the concern but this
is an important consideration for us and
finally um the requirements of hospit
319 are for students at New Hampshire's
public colleges and universities only if
finding and taking this test is at all
an onerous requirement and it may not be
but if it is this bill May create a
disincentive for students to enroll at
our colleges in favor of Institutions
that don't have this requirement such as
private colleges or other types of
training programs or colleges across our
borders um again if if accessing this
test is a fairly simple matter then this
would be less of a concern for us so to
to wrap up um we certainly understand
the desire for our citizenry to
demonstrate knowledge about the Civic
life and Foundation of our state and our
nation and and we commend the sponsor
really for his his his attention to this
his examples and his his testimony and
and his intent um our concerns really
are um more of a practical nature so I
I'll be happy to answer any questions if
I can and I I do know the $10 bill one
mfet sorry I just asked question
question
joing let's go ahead here with u
questions are any questions for the
system thank you Mr chairman thank you
Miss re for taking a question what per I
know the community colleges offers
courses in the trades and whatnot and I
also remember National Community colge
some years ago we had one Governor Judge
Greg Supreme Court Justice judge sud
discussing Civics and the requirements
my question is what what percentage of
community college students actually
tra I think your question was what
percentage of our students graduate with
a degree in the trades yeah um I don't
know the precise percentage and and you
know the trades isn't what it used to be
in terms of you know our students will
graduate for instance with an Associate
Degree in welding technology or an
automotive technology I mean those are
those are full-fledged degrees there
also shorter term certificate options
for those too so I think there's a
little more blending than your question
um necessarily um suggests in terms of
of of an answer
but if I'm guessing I would
say
40% maybe or you know what I'm gonna
have to I'm gonna have to get back to
with a more precise number because I
don't want to I don't want to answer
thank you very much Shannon are there
further questions for the community of
college thank you very much thank
you we have P o'ri from the New England
Commission of higher education go ahead
please thank you very much uh thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
uh my name is Pat O'Brien and I am here
on behalf of the New England Commission
of higher education Nei to speak about
House Bill 39 19 as you may know Nei is
the higher education accrediting agency
that accredits colleges and universities
in the six New England States including
the public colleges and universities of
New Hampshire institutions receive many
benefits from being accredited by Nei
not the least of which is that their
students qualify to receive federal
financial aid such as pel grants and
Stafford Loans and the institutions
themselves qualify for federal grants
through for example NIH or
NSF I was asked by the community college
system of New Hampshire to discuss
whether implementation of the
requirement noted in House Bill 319
would raise any concerns about
institution's ability to meet
accreditation requirements ne's
requirements for accreditation are
outlined in its standards for
accreditation which are available on the
commission's website nti.org
institutions demonstrate their
compliance with the standards through
submission of reports a comprehensive
self-study every 10 years an interim
report at the fifth year point of the 10
year cycle and progress reports as
requested by the commission the reports
are reviewed by the members of the
commission who make the decision about
whether an institution is in compliance
with the standard there are some places
in the standards for implementation of
the requirement of House Bill 319 may
affect institutional compliance with the
standards the standard on organization
and governance expects that the
institution will have quote sufficient
autonomy and control of its programs
operations end quote imposition of a
graduation requirement by the
legislature may suggest that the
institution's autonomy and control is
insufficient the standard also expects
that the institution will place quote
primary responsibility for the content
quality and effectiveness of the
curriculum with its faculty close quote
imp position of a graduation requirement
again may suggest that faculty do not
have the primary responsibility
stipulated by this stand
standard three expectations contained in
the standard on the academic program are
relevant here first the institution is
expected to demonstrate quote its clear
and ongoing Authority and administrative
oversight for the academic elements of
all courses for which it Awards
institutional credit or credentials
second the institutions quote evaluation
of student learning or achievement and
the award of credit end quote is
expected to be quote based on clearly
stated criteria that reflect learning
objectives and are consistently and
effectively applied and finally from the
standard on academic program the
institution's award of credit is
expected to be quote consistent with
commission policy and the course content
appropriate to the field of study and
reflect the level and amount of student
learning and be based on policies
developed and overseen by the faculty
and academic Administration end quote
again uh the imposition of a graduation
requirement by the legislature may
suggest that the institution does not
possess the requisite Authority and
oversight and or that its graduation
requirements are not determined by its
faculty and academic
Administration finally the standard on
students expects that the institution
will assess its quote efforts to achieve
an equitable educational experience for
all of its students close quote and as
I've listened to uh the discussion today
the testimony today I realize that there
are different considerations about how
the test may be administered or what it
might cost to take that test but the US
citizenship and immigration services
website notes that the current filing
fee to take the test is
$725 assuming that students need to pay
that fee in order to meet a graduation
requirement questions could be raised
about the institution's effort to
provide that Equitable educational
experience required by the standard
given that students will have varying
ability to pay that fee I'll be happy to
provide a written copy of my remarks or
Andor to answer any questions that you
may have and I thank you for your
attention thank you very much are there
any questions of
nii I have one question for you um an
institution like UNH offers a bachelor's
degree perhaps the in agriculture may be
a two-year um they also offer Masters
and doctoral programs
I in looking at this bill would this uh
requirement uh could it be applied to a
UNH is that a
question me this this requirement that
you have to take this uh citizenship
test in order to graduate um is a
doctoral degree the same as a ba or BS
as far as grad
graduating yes the the expectation is
that the institution has the autonomy to
set the graduation requirements for all
the degrees that it
Awards whether it be a Balor or a
Masters or a doctoral degree thank you
very much are there any further
the I I would like a copy of your your
points in your statement would you email
that to us uh yes what I'll do is I'll
email it to Shannon Reed I think she
knows better how to reach you than I do
thank you okay thank you very much F the
questions thank you very much thank you
thank you for your
attention Okay um Mr chair there are no
other people signed up to
testify okay we have no other people to
testify this time so we are going to cud
this conclude this hearing uh today on
319 uh what was our score in terms of uh
yep so we have four four people signed
in in support four supporting 61 opposed
61 opposed three neutral three neutral
and three testify and three
testify thank you very much so this
concludes that hearing and we'll move
into the last hearing before lunch today
that is uh HB
339 establishing a committee to Quality
in school
buildings 330
find representa suvin and Shu are the
two reps on that bill yep um
representative Sullivan I have promoted
um welcome to education and I will
well welcome represent
Sullivan thank you Mr
chair my name is Brian Sullivan
representing um Sullivan County district
one which is includes a planfield
Cornish Grantham and
Springfield it is my uh job today to
introduce House Bill 3
339 um this house bill will establish a
legislative committee to study indoor
air quality in schools it is nearly
identical to to a house bill from last
year House Bill
111 1118 from last year last year's bill
passed the committee with an 18 to to
two vote and passed the house in a Voice
vote it then went on to die a covid
death in the
Senate this bill was a good idea last
year and is a crucial concept now that
the Pand pandemic has arrived in the
best of times indoor air quality is a
persistent problem in many school bu
buildings a according to the EPA air
pollutants not can be two to five times
and occasionally up to a 100 times
greater than um outdoor levels the EPA
and its science Advisory Board
consistently rank indoor air pollution
among the top five environmental um
health risks to the public this is
especially important to schools as
children may be more susceptible to air
pollutants now that we are grappling
with the covid pandemic the issue of add
addressing viral contamination is a
pressing concern along with the isue
issue of indoor air
pollution RSA 200 um col
11-a requires that the school principal
or design conduct an annual air quality
investigation by filling out a checklist
this procedure clearly is not sufficient
as complaints of poor air quality
persist the EPA teamed with the Harvard
School of Public Health to study the
issue of air quality in schools
I would suggest that the study committee
of from this bill utilize the experts
associated with the Harvard study to
assist in studying New Hampshire
schools one advantage we have this year
is addressing this concept in the first
year of the
vium this will give the study committee
two years to conduct its work the
committee the committee report is due
November 1
20122 this is a this is a crucial issue
that should be thoroughly
investigated the committee will also be
hearing from Jen given a teacher from
Hollis Brookline School District to
provide firsthand information regarding
air quality in schools Brian Hawkins
will provide broader testimony across a
wider range of districts I'd be happy to
take any questions from the
committee thank you very much
representative are there questions for
the
representative um I did you have a
question Hopson uh thank you for taking
my qu my question um representative lad
and representative Sullivan um I was
doing some research and found that there
were two other bills hb1
1265 and hb1
1289 uh both of those bills one was in
2000 I think they were both in
2010 and they they put um investigation
of air quality Tools for
Schools um and then the school board in
each School District to um
Implement policies to address air
quality um are
these uh are these measures not enough
is that what you're saying uh by putting
this bill
forward the information that has been
coming from well thank you for the
question um the information we've been
getting from the schools um from from uh
staff members from schools um has been
that uh the problem persists um and so
the efforts that were made 10 years ago
um clearly we're not sufficient to um
address the uh the problems so yes I
guess I would agree that um um the
efforts 10 years ago were not
sufficient further questions
repres thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative um I was just wondering
if you were uh aware of the federal uh S
one and two funds um that are available
to school TOS that
uh Encompass air quality is one of the
uh items that can be a source of
expenditures I believe there's something
like $36 million in extra one and over
$150 million in exra two um so it seems
to me that there are are federal funds
available to meet air quality um issues
in local school rules uh and I was just
wondering if if you thought that a
commission was required in addition to
um these federal funds that are already
available thank you for the question um
the um I I guess the this is not a
commission this is a study committee um
but I believe the study committee um
could very well provide information to
um uh the department as well as
individual school districts so that they
could utilize those funds in an
effective manner um it's one thing to
have funds it's another thing to know
them thank you very
much thank you very much Mr chair and
and uh actually this is a this is a
question for you for uh for the chair um
uh I heard um representative Sullivan
talk about some people that I think are
going to be following him testifying um
I'm not sure if I heard him say Amy
Clark um director Clark's name from the
department but I do see her as a as an
attendee at this meeting and I and I do
know that the department does collect um
air quality uh information self-reported
from school districts as as she um
presented um well you remember Rick
during the during the school funding
commission so I was wondering if she was
also going to be speaking this morning
well we do have uh a clar available to
us uh and the other part too is that
remember we did uh retain
214 which deals with building
construction build and at that time we
reference the S money and I'll read uh
the 14th item that comes 14th um uh
directive that comes down and how we can
use that money it says inspection
testing maintenance repair replacement
and upgrade projects to improve the the
indoor air quality in school facilities
including mechanical and nonmechanical
heating ventilation and air conditioning
systems filtering purification and other
cleaning fans control systems and
windows door repair and replacement so
that Esra money is wide open in terms of
addressing some of the issues which
represent solent is uh supporting and we
also have that other bill which we
retain with the thought looking at this
broad picture of school building Aid and
maintaining our
buildings do you have anything else add
from that yeah yeah just just to add to
that um Mr chair and and I absolutely
agree with what what you just said there
except that money is not just up for
grabs it um it it does get allocated out
on a you know on a basis that's not left
up to the uh to the local school
districts which I think brings even
greater importance to what um uh what
representative Sullivan is talking about
here in terms of working with
information we have and being able to
assist um the um U the the executive
branch in um in determining in directing
where these funds were they're most
needed yes you're correct that the funds
are coming down through the department
from the federal government and it
allows these local school districts they
may use this funds these funds in a
direction that they feel that best you
know directs efforts to correct some of
the covid related concerns and it has to
be Co related and that's where here
quity hops in there maybe the next thing
we ought to do if there's no more
questions represent you have a question
that mine is just to ask yeah to ask
representative suan to send his uh uh
statement to the committee that's my
only question we have that
yeah it' be nice if you have a statement
that you could get to us represent Sol
so we can make sure it's in the minutes
I can do
that thank
you yeah we can have representative
shuck next and then we'll have following
represent Shu will have uh Amy Clark
from the
Department anybody else for a question
for representative
solivan thank you very much
representative
solivan uh representative Shu are you
there
yes I am thank you Mr chair um for the
record I am uh co-sponsor of this bill
Diane shuid I represent miramac 20 the
towns of Pembrook and
Chichester uh I had not actually signed
up to speak I had justed uh in favor of
uh the bill and as the co-sponsor uh I
feel it's a very important issue and as
has been stated this study would
identify the best ways to use funds that
may be available and which schools uh
should be prioritized perhaps uh with
that I think probably
questions uh would be better directed to
some of the more expert folks that are
waiting to speak thank you thank you
very much representative uh let's bring
up director from Department of
educ uh Amy Clark you've been promoted
are you there Amy I am can you hear me
yes we can sorry about that actually
just got booted off but I am back on so
um for the record my name is Amy Clark
and I'm with the Department of Education
I'm the administrator for the school
safety and facility management Bureau
and I'm really here just to take your
questions so I don't have any specific
testimony I think the only take-home
message I would say for for indoor air
quality issues is that they existed
before covid um so they are an ongoing
issue whether it's mold or dust or
whether it's maintenance issues or
proper humidity control or proper air
Handling Systems all problems that
existed before
Co is just much much tinier than some of
the other pollutants that we're dealing
with but makes it more challenging are
the questions reps on the no thank you
very much Mr chair and thank you very
much Miss Clark for joining us this
morning um I was wondering if you could
just talk a little bit about the um the
indoor air quality survey that uh that
the department collects uh I think every
year and I know you've provided um to
the school funding commission and um uh
if you could just sort of tell us what
that's about and and some of the things
that um that the Department's learned
from that
um sure um the requirement is that the
department put out this checklist which
schools fill out every year um it was
really a data collection tool um and
schools uh it's now on a more formal
survey in the past few years we've
gotten much better reporting um on from
school's reporting than in the past but
really it's just data collection there's
no
um if you know there's no followup on
that there's no no penalties there's no
you know we just use it to talk to
schools when they have complaint issues
or something use it as a tool when we're
doing their school approval
work quick followup yes go ahead Mr
chair thanks so so thanks thanks very
much Miss Clark um I I was also hoping
you might be able to sort of comment on
some of the things that that that you
see in that um survey such as some
schools have very robust air handling
and and um filtration systems while
other schools
um don't have those types of systems and
don't even have the ability to um to do
even a a single exchange of uh of of air
um during the day um sure so that's um
that's true all as I think probably most
of the committee knows is that um but
just to restate that schools are all
different and built in all different
years there are building codes that
require that they meet ashray standards
which are essentially air quality
standards and but it's at the time the
building was constructed so you can
imagine newer schools that are built um
today um are at much different um
standards than schools that were built a
100 years ago and some of them 50 years
ago um a lot of our school buildings are
much older so you're not going to find a
building that was built 60 years ago
with um a robust air handling system um
some schools have trouble just opening
their windows I mean I'm not joking they
have tools that they've developed from
facility managers being creative and
finding a poll with a hook and try to um
get that door or window open um and some
schools burn up in the September and
some schools freeze in certain days of
year so yeah the built in the last 10
years will look a lot different than
schools built 50 years ago for sure air
especially you
question yes thank you Mr chairman Miss
clar thank you for taking my question um
just on
a geez I'm sorry
go
down I'm sorry Mr
Woodcock go ahead yeah thank you I don't
know what happened I want spinning
around here um seems to my status don't
laugh Mullen um M Clark thank you so
much for taking the question just in
general terms um from your annual review
reports and data about how many schools
do you think uh percentage was 20 40 90
Z need uh a change an upgrade in air
quality HVAC systems in our in our
state I can get you a better number I
actually do have some of those numbers
sorry I don't have them available at my
fingertips um but the when I looked at
the survey data so um to back up this
survey comes out every year at in about
April is time frame so our survey isn't
really geared toward um questions covid
related questions because came up last
April whereas this year we'll ask a
little bit better question suited to
some of the things that we're looking
for but um I remember looking through
that data and I wasn't able to determine
uh I I'll get you that data there was
some question about it but in general
there's a significant amount of
schools that
um keep in mind that you can't just put
a new air handling system in a school
and expect the school walls the whole
the building itself to be able to um
produce the air exchange that you're
looking for um it really goes down to
Major construction and renovation
projects that will be able to address
their air quality issues um but let me
get you some numbers to you and I will
email the committee and it's essentially
numbers of people who have being able to
have fresh air and those who don't okay
just to follow representative lad go
ahead Miss Clark um please don't invest
a whole lot of time digging out that
data um but thank you I was just looking
for a general a general opinion based on
your ongoing knowledge yeah yeah I
actually do have that data available
quite quickly but I appreciate thank you
thank you thank you are there further
questions for the
Department Amy I have one for you um
when you do this survey are you also
surveying the 28 quer technical centers
and the facilities they have I know some
are in wonderful facilities others are
are are in rooms much like a
classroom uh for the most part yes we
have a couple of Standalone Career and
Technical education centers that are not
included in that survey but high schools
are I presume are answering the when the
high school fills it out they're they're
addressing the whole High School I
presume we don't separate out between
CTE centers in high schools but the
Standalone CTE centers I imagine are not
included
I of at
least thank you are there further
questions for the
Department okay there's a question
represent you have a question yes thank
you chairman thank you m CLK um I was
wondering if you were involved at all in
the review of the plans that are
submitted by by districts for use of the
Esser PLS um I am not I'm not um our
administrator for that is Katie Murphy
who is handling that and that does not
currently come through my office
um if she's on the phone she could
certainly correct me if I'm wrong but
from what I understand sr1 versus sr2
sr2 is now involves some construction
where sr1 funds did not and so I'm not
sure if those details are still being
worked out uh but for the most part uh I
don't I don't believe that they'll get
any official facility review through the
department it will be that the schools
are identifying their needs and
installing what they need it's a a
little federal funds require uh
different construction standards um than
State funds do for example they have to
follow Davis bacon rules and um and
other standards for federal funding that
schools are not used to going through
because there's not been any federal
funding for construction um so that
might be a little bit of um things that
they may get up to speed with but they
don't go for my
thank you very much
question thank you very
much next we have Jennifer given uh
representing herself go ahead you've
been
promoted good morning thank you so much
for taking the time to hear my testimony
um I really appreciate it especially
right before lunch um so I am a teacher
I am also the president of the uh
Teachers Association at Hollis and
Brooklyn uh Cooperative District I teach
at the high school uh I can speak to uh
kind of the firsthand account if you
will of the experience that we have as
uh people who are uh working within a
school our school was built um to kind
of dub tail on a couple of the other
comments uh about 25 years ago uh so we
I think might be kind of that um case
study of we're not modern in terms of
our um infrastructure but we are
certainly not the one that's going to
fall apart anytime soon and so um in
some ways we're we're in the worst
position because we would not qualify
perhaps for some of that emergency um
priority construction whereas um you
know we are definitely struggling with
some significant air quality issues um
so just to kind of uh give you a sense
of the impact um Every Spring and then
of course in every in the fall uh we
enter into the building um buildings are
uh we have conflicting protocols so one
of the things that we need to do is keep
Kids Safe which of course we all would
support that means every afternoon we
need to lock the building down close
windows shut everything up um that kind
of flies in the face of this competing
need for improved air quality which I
mean if you grew up in New Hampshire
like I did the trick for when we were
little was open up all the windows at
night let the cooler air kind of flow
through then shut them all up in the
morning and like have the building kind
of cool off we do the exact opposite um
and we do that because we need to to
keep the building secure of course we do
but we are even limited in our um kind
of DIY air quality efforts by um by some
of those restrictions for for things
like that we are also limited like uh I
was told a couple years ago we can't
have any more classroom fans because
they spread allergens right and they can
but we are also then competing against
the okay but we're all incredibly
uncomfortable it's really hot and humid
and the kid with asthma is being
triggered by that condition and so
schools really do desperately need a
standard that is um adopted and then
enforced uh and then of course we need
the support to help uh get that
infrastructure in place um right now
what happens is in the fall we run
things like SATs and in the spring we
run some high stakes Tes in both of
which those conditions we tend to put
kids into a space where it's really hot
and sticky and we know from um
developmental psychology studies that
their cognitive ability drops so we're
pairing all of these competing demands
on these kids uh and it's it's just
really unfair um kids don't have an
option to not attend school of course
this year we can attend in a myriad of
ways but typically they are required to
attend and be in the building and again
I agree with that but what they don't
then have is any control over their own
um experience in that day when it comes
to temperature or air quality and so
they can be exposed to all sorts of
things um and they're required to be
there so for me it's a um it's a health
issue but it's a moral issue and it's a
learning issue kids do not learn well
when they are um hot and uncomfortable
or when they feel like they can't
breathe well and we have a lot of data
that supports that and we also have a
lot of data that supports um the
increase to our health office visits uh
really spikes on on those hot days with
dizzy and nausea and headaches and you
know all of those things um but then
also the social and emotional if you are
a teenage kid um you are hyper aware of
how you look who you're sitting next to
all that kind of stuff um and if you're
hot and sticky you're you're even more
distracted from the learning that you're
supposed to be doing right like um I
have a couple of teenagers who I live
with and I can attest I can attest to
the fact that they are very much aware
of how they look at any particular
moment um and the perception of that and
also you can really tell the difference
between kids who um socioeconomic
backgrounds who who can kind of manage
those things a little bit more
comfortably than others they might have
um their personal fans and like you know
all those things that come with them um
and so you I would argue that we really
need uh the state to intervene because
at the local level we are putting out
the most immediate fire right and this
year that's covid um and so all of our
Focus has really gone there which has
meant that all the other goals that we
might want to meet need to take a back
burner we we just don't have the
bandwidth to do all of the things and so
it would be lovely if the state of New
Hampshire um got us some really solid
data to to kind of use as a way to then
gauge how much mitigation efforts we
really need um and then hopefully uh
require some of that so that students
can have the health benefits of of
building thank you very much are there
question welcome you're welcome for
missg just a quick one yes repr Lun
thanks very much um Mr chair thank you
very much Miss given for joining us this
morning um so would you classify um
indoor air quality as both a health
issue and as well as a student Equity
issue absolutely um because students who
are able to um cool off are are going to
be able to learn better sometimes that
can't happen at home and that should
happen in the building right like that's
the one space that we can actually offer
an equal playing field um and what we
are really doing is kind of the opposite
we're taking all these kids from
different maybe they had advantages at
home and then we're putting them in a
disadvantaged environment and giving
them high St Tess um so I guess that's a
way to equalize the playing field but I
don't think that's what we intended you
know um so it would be it would be
lovely if kids if schools were places
that were physically safe in all way not
just from you know we we do a lot of
lockdown or active shooter drills but it
also needs to be safe in like the
daytoday kind of mundane ways of
comfortable and and reasonable air um
you know that people learn and work
better when they are not freezing or hot
so um or it can take a deep breath which
is also a good
questions thank you very much for your
testimony today thank you so much for
having me I appreciate it wel uh we
don't have anyone else signed up to
testify but there is uh an attendee who
has his hand
raised
okay okay go ahead uh Brian welcome to
education
thank you very much Mr chairman can
everybody hear me okay yes great um I'll
try and be brief um uh want to thank
representative Sullivan for bringing the
bill forward um we're in full support of
House Bill
339 um you know who knew this bill would
take on a whole another meeting meeing
than when this came before uh this
committee uh just a year ago
um you I think what uh Jen just
described um again uh sort of taking on
a whole new meeting um this was an issue
the issue of air quality in our schools
before the pandemic um it's been an
issue during the pandemic and I think
the value of having this study committee
is to help ensure um that we can take a
hard look at this so that it is not an
issue continuing to be an issue going
forward when we exit the pandemic um she
gave some good examples of of you know
issues non-co
related uh that that that has persisted
in our um schools I mean like issues of
uh you know like structural issues such
as
Broadband um you know we ought to come
out of this pandemic you know stronger
for our kids um than we did going in and
um I I uh I believe you have some
written comments from um Lori Hayes
who's one of our uh uniserve directors
she works with a particular region of of
the state um just just one of of 10
regions um and she cites some some you
know scary examples of of of issues of
prepandemic air quality um that I can
tell you there are issues all over the
state um that that mirror some of those
uh uh I think Miss Clark you know
referenced it in her comments earlier
that you know we have a lot of old
buildings in the state and and with that
comes um a myriad of issues including um
including this so you know uh some of
those uh conditions so you know you can
you can lead in um in Lor's written
testimony and uh would certainly be
happy to work with the the committee
should it be become law um one piece of
that that I'll just uh uh reference very
quickly uh and representative Sullivan
brought up is uh the Harvard School
study from
2017 um which states that um the quality
and characteristics of our schools have
an outsized impact on the health of our
students um by the time a student
graduates from high school uh she or he
has spent 15,600 hours inside a school
uh maybe not this year but um and amount
of time uh second only to that at home
and that there are nationwide there's
more than 50 million K through 12
students in the United States um the
time spent in school is also a time of
Rapid physical growth hormonal changes
intense learning and as uh as as Jen um
referenced you know critical
neurological and Social Development um
and unfortunately you know poor air
quality uh can take a toll on on that
development um so I I I would hope that
that would be a study that this
committee would would would would look
at um look at the laws and rules that
may need updating as a result of this
and then um just to to reference quickly
the the circumstances that were in now
the crisis we're in now with with
respect to the pandemic um you know all
the Myriad of of standards that are out
there from the CDC um to the um to the
uh
uh to the ashray standards that Miss
Clark uh referenced um you know there
are some very specific uh
recommendations guidelines in there um
that I think you know committee and
could help uh you know develop some
systems for ensuring that our schools
have these you know some of the specific
ones would just include things like you
know uh setting hbac systems uh at
certain uh uh settings with respect to
outdoor air uh increasing U the air flow
Supply to occupied spaces especially
places like uh you know nursing uh
nursing stations and schools um um and
then uh you know also in the before and
after period of the of the school day so
um again we think this bill is about um
safety um safety for our students safety
for our educators
um we've heard that uh with respect to
the pandemic Co is going to be around
for a long time um even even after we're
all most of us are vaccinated it will
still be something that is uh is around
and we should do our best to try and
protect against that and as well as the
next hopefully not for a long time but
the next issue related to air quality
whether that's something that's
transmitted through the air or some some
of the day-to-day issues that that that
existed before so um I'll close my
testimony there um and uh urge you to
pass House Bill 339 thank you very much
thank you very much Brian are there
questions for Mr
Hawkins not seeing any hands thank you
very much okay appreciate your
time okay that should take us through I
I believe our testimony on on this
particular bill can uh do you have the
number of people that y yep uh we had 12
signing and support 12 supporting zero
opposed zero opposed zero neutral zero
neutral and we had uh three testify
five five oh
miss
yeah yeah I agree okay thank you very
much well so this closes uh down the uh
hb33 when we come back from lunch we're
going to go and look at Acoustics and
buildings that's the next bill we hop on
the docket
267 so thank you very much we will come
back and we will start at 12:45 thank
one where
they who they represent and whether
and
all where are we here
okay okay we're going to go ahead and
continue now with our hearings for today
four bills left uh we're on 267 that's
relative to construction standards for
schools and represent PE is
here to introduce the bill you're
recognized representative thank
you of the comme my name is Mark Pearson
state representative for
pensed I chair the health human services
and elderly Affairs Committee of the
house I also chair the New Hampshire
Commission on deafness and hearing loss
but of particular relevance to this bill
I share the advis com for the education
of students who were de and part of
hearing a group which has six
subcommittees actively working on
various aspects of the delivery of
services to our death and heart of
hearing students in New
Hampshire one of the members of this
council is an educational
audiologist her travels throughout New
Hampshire she has discovered that many
schools are exemplary in how they
educate their children with this and
with other studies
however she has discovered other schools
that needs some help the purpose of our
council is to identify specific areas of
need so help can be better
rendered one area of concern is the
noise generated by Antiquated hbac
systems the special devices most of our
deaf and hard hearing students can
participate in mainstream
education however noisy hbac systems
make learning quite difficult to despite
those special
devices her experience and recent
conversations with colleagues say that
as many as 60% of the HVAC systems do
not meet
standards Federal Law requires our
schools to provide a proper atmosphere
for learning some have suggested
my commission or my councel or both um
bring lawsuits against school
districts but both my commission my
councel and myself I prefer to alert
local officials to the problems and give
them some your
suffix bipartison House Bill 267 offers
a way forward that is helpful to Heart
aing students and to do it in a way that
school districts can
plan we do have standards for new
buildings in terms of noise from H but
not subsequent
inspections to me this is like having
your car inspected when it's brand new
on for lot but never having it
inspected there is some money available
on Friday morning February 26 I spoke to
Sten Murphy the department of
education's administrator of new Co
money available to schools
Co pmic making us very much more aware
of issues of ventilation and air quality
and you heard a bill on that this
morning I understand that some school
districts are
contemplating a thorough examination of
how their HX system moves air
around why not are they Antiquated and
the
need some standard H systems May exess
survey the transfer of the virus
throughout the school and might not
acccess noise be an indicator of
substandard
assists so there seems to be a need it
will help students in need so they can
continue to be
M seems to be money available and on
behalf of hard appearance students in
our school I actually pass house bu to
thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much Mr
represent pearon it's hard looking at
here thank you very much represent
representative are there questions for
represent pearon represent
wood thank you representative lad uh
representative Pearson thank you for
taking the question just um just two two
I think um the first one is uh B looking
at the dates the dates of this
sequencing of the building in 2026 and
the date of
Passage if a school system
today is halfway done a construction
project uh and it'll be finished say in
October of October
uh and there be P the 60 days does that
mean when you when you go to the 2026
date you have here does that mean mean
if they aren't in compliance they have
to have it done by
2026 if they're not in compliance now
has to be done by
2026 follow up Mr chair yes you may so U
and I don't know the answer I wouldn't
ask the question Mr pearon the the the
uh Ani requirements that you site are
those currently being used by uh schools
in New School design
typically what I've been told is that
when new schools are being built they
have to meet those
standards okay um old
schs that's my concern okay and then one
one final question I may Mr lad I won't
ask any more of this candidate this
person representative the the I'm
looking at the standards for uh physical
education teaching
environment um and in some of the
smaller schools the elementary schools
often that physical education
environment is also the uh cafeteria
school lunch area or the school
auditorium
so which which what are they using here
the cafeteria noise level or and I don't
know what I don't know what a physical
education uh environment is in terms of
the noise level where so much of that is
is done in large gymnasiums even the new
school the large gymnasium versus
uh they the phys teachers teach in the
gymnasium but it's it's used primarily
as the
gymnasium um or the small elementary
schools they may teach fizet in the in
the cafeteria so can can you just give
me some Enlightenment on that please
absolutely not I hav AOL on but I would
suspect that students who have
difficulty in hearing their classroom
would probably not wisely be in an area
with a tremendous Echo that problem will
pop up immediately long before any H
[Music]
questions well I can highly hear your
answer but thank
up are there further questions ref
Ellison thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you
represent for taking my question uh I I
just clarification should there be a
fiscal note on this bill or are you
assuming that everything that's needed
and required under the bill will be
handled with covid funding that may be
coming forward I'm assuming that what
this B asks for will be handled by
however simply because the standards
that the federal laws require is an
atmosphere conducive to learning and
um
LLY if the HVAC noise level doesn't get
fixed in school there were people
prepared to do lawsuit so my concern was
not to go that well simply say schools I
know a lot of schools are looking at
their HS because they transfer air I
know a lot of schools will conclude if
the h fact is noisy it's probably not
doing a good job I also know that I'm
told that thereal money coming for
school to change things because of Co
and I also know that there's um
according to the Department of
education's administrator of the new Co
money uh to point out that an air
exchange system in school needs to be
tested and brought up to Cod
is exactly what a CO kind of use of
money would be which is a long way of
saying we don't think there needed to be
a
fisal thank
you are there further questions
represent M yes thank you Mr chairman
and thank you representative Pearson for
taking my question um representative
Woodcock alluded to the uh August 1 2026
deadline for compliance for existing
buildings Roman three of your bill line
20 says a school district May request a
waiver from the Department of Ed for
meeting the requirements in this
section um I'm a little confused as to
whether or not we're saying two opposite
things one they must comply by 2026 and
two they can get a a waiver or is there
something in section three is that's
being waved that isn't stated in the
bill um my reading of it is that a
school district can request anything
they want and if the Department of
Education doesn't think it's a very good
waiver I think the reason that I was
asked to put in that is we don't know
what we don't know and we may encounter
something quite odd down the road where
a waiver would make sense on a one-time
basis okay thank you uh represent
repres my question is about the learning
spaces used as a primary education space
for a child who death or heart of
hearing uh would that child be moving
from
classroom that's in line 16 and 17 would
the child be moving from classroom to
classroom and is that something that
then would be harder to accomplish I
I would assume that if there is a
classroom where proper delivery of
instruction to a child who has hearing
difficulties the child would not be put
in that room either the problem would be
fixed or accommodations would be made
right now I am told by people
who there are some schools where that's
being done but you know the higher up
you go and the more a child changes
classes there can be a bit of a problem
there and this V just says fix the
problem thank
you are there further
questions not see any hands thank you
very much our
representative okay next we have uh
Linda Taylor she has um signed in and
support and uh
she she has indicated zero minutes but I
have a feeling it's probably going to be
longer than
[Music]
that hi thank you very much for allowing
me to speak um I'm Linda Taylor and I'm
a teacher of Da and heart of hearing
students and I've been working in the
state since 1997 as an educational
consultant and itinerant teacher um I
have degrees uh including a doctorate
from Boston University in this area um
and I'm speaking here here in favor of
HP 267 because I know how important good
Acoustics are for both me and my
students um the NC standards for
classroom Acoustics have already been
adopted by um Connecticut and Minnesota
and um some cities including New York
city so that answers um the
representative's earlier
question however somewhere around 30% of
classrooms today have been found to meet
those standards um they hope us here by
reducing background noise to a level uh
akin to a very quiet spoken um voice of
35db um they suggest Renovations using
less permeable doors and windows um and
they reduce reverberation or Echo time
to um a manageable um amount of time I
found in my experience traveling around
New Hampshire um that poor Acoustics are
a major impediment to the effect Ive
education of De and hard fairing
students and that alone would justify
this legislation however foring
Acoustics also hinder the education of
children with perfect tearing um
especially those under 13 our brains
haven't developed enough to be able to
push away background noise and Home in
on what we want to hear um and it also
impedes the education of English
language Learners and then students with
other disabilities such as attention
so that is one side of it the other side
is that um teachers are straining to
have their voices heard over um
background noise and so we know that um
teachers have a 20% greater risk of
damaging their voices more than other
professions just because they're trying
so hard to project to the back row you
add open doors and windows with covid
you add masks with covid and the
teachers themselves are taking more sick
days than they would normally have to
wear Acoustics to be
better I like to draw the the comparison
to a classroom that is lit by one single
40 watt light bulb the teacher can hear
the front row the teacher can see the
front row can see but the kids in the
back or the middle of the classroom are
going to be squinting to follow what's
going on and in some classrooms that 40
watt light bulb is what is going on
acoustically um we wouldn't accept this
in a classroom um but research um on
classrooms close to highways and Subway
systems have found that um children have
a one-year drop in academic achievement
for every additional 10 dbb of
background
noise there is at least one school in
New Hampshire um where the HVAC noise
level in an empty classroom has been
measured at 60 DB that's a
conversational speed each level if you
think about that that translates to two
years of delay in academics if you
extrapolate from that research so poor
Acoustics are a significant barrier to
learning in my
opinion um I was involved in writing
rule
32121 in this area in
2005 little has happened since um it
seems that uh new and renovated schools
don't consider Acoustics important
enough to include um and they're
definitely not a priority I'm hopeful
that this legislation will pass and then
create the teeth we need to provide all
of our students the learning environment
that they and all of our death in the
heart of hearing students need thank you
very much thank you very much Miss
Taylor see Hands thank you very much
thank
you
[Music]
ording oh I'm sorry I didn't see that uh
Gary
Abbott a AGC of New Hampshire oh there's
Amy
okay
there you are I didn't see
her thank you and representative Hobson
I just suck my hand up while you were
looking down so I would being easy um
and I apologize for not signing in to
testify um when I went to do so too late
so I'm sorry about that uh I do just
want to point out again for the record
my name is Amy Clark and I'm with the
Department of Education and um we are
neutral on this bill but I do just want
to point out a couple of things um with
this bill um keep in mind um Ed 321 are
our um regulations on minimum
construction standards currently there
is already a requirement for schools
that are under construction to meet this
ansy
regulation uh and if I recall the last
time this regulation was updated was
Medan 2010 meaning the an standard I
think was um most um recently updated in
2010 um so when a building is goes under
construction with building Aid uh they
come through our office and we review
those standards and we have a sign off
on an architect from the architect that
it meets those acoustic
standards the regulation requires that
all buildings meet this with or without
building Aid so however there's just no
oversight from the Department without
any um State funds involved um so I just
want to point that out um and
um the other thing is that these are
some of my questions would be that how
is a school um will they know if they
meet these um acoustical standards there
might be complaints which might lead
them to realize that they don't but
unless you potentially have like an
Acoustics engineer go in and do an
assessment of the building buildings
won't necessarily know if they meet
those standards or not and I'd also just
like to say like the to be clear for us
building to come up to these acoustic
standards not fut I don't see any issues
with new construction and new renovation
spaces to be able to meet these
standards that should be something
completely doable and currently
required however um my only concern
would be how a school would come up to
these standards in the next 5 years and
keep in mind lots and lots of school
buildings have bookcases dividing their
classrooms they have partition walls
they have temporary walls they have
walls that only go partially to the
ceiling all of those spaces um won't
meet these standards um schools have
spaces where they've taken one large
room and just uh divided it with all
sorts of weird things um to make the
space that they need so construction
reconstruction I understand how they'll
do that I'm just unclear how schools
will be doing that um for the for the
2023 that doesn't mean that it's not
important so I want to be very clear
that Acoustics and learning is very
important and I would agree with what
the um other speakers said that um
it's very important which is why they're
in our minimum construction standards I
just I'm not sure the covid money um
will be able to address that unless
schools are already looking at it
specifically for their hbac then that
might make sense but it's more than just
systems for a
post and
um that's all my comments I looked over
my list so I think I covered them and
I'm happy to answer any questions if you
have any thank you are there any
questions for the
Department Amy I have one and then I see
Dave Runo has one um in the survey that
you have conducted in the past for our
schools that we talked about previously
before lunch and at other times uh are
there any questions on that survey
dealing with
sounds there there are not it's strictly
an indoor air
survey okay so when you're doing a
survey to discern age of our
buildings what's in the walls and all
that I know in the past we've just had
the school custodian or maintenance
person or principal do that so there's
absolutely nothing there in that survey
dealing with acoustical situations I
don't think so I can't see the relation
obviously there's a relation between
HVAC noise um and but other than that in
the indoor air quality survey there is
not we have a regular like a volunteer
facility survey that we're that we put
out uh
and um that also I don't think has any
um questions about and I have one other
followup to that then Dave um talked
about oversight and there's basically
very little oversight coming from the
Department you just don't have the St
you don't have the engineers to do this
uh is it naturally the responsibility of
the state or the local to have this
over well I will just say the minimum
construction standards are a standard
for schools to have to build to uh but
with keep in mind so since the 1940s the
building Aid has been available to
schools for construction and the state
reviewed all of those construction
projects because they always went
through the Department of Education
because they were funded based on need
of schools but since 2010 building a has
not been funded therefore those projects
have not gone through our office but
that didn't make the minimum
construction standards go away so um but
there's no requirement for schools to
report or have sign offs or they're just
standards they have to me kind of you
know if anything potentially the local
building um code officer might might
look at acustic standards but I imagine
that that depends on each Town um and I
wouldn't I wouldn't bu bet on that I
think that they probably mostly building
code and fire
code thank you very
much thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much again Miss Clark for
joining us this afternoon for um uh for
the buildings that were um that were
constructed prior to the um the acoustic
standards you know laid out in the ansy
um um standard are there um is there
potential I guess for Adaptive
Technologies such as um uh F audio
transmission um systems that I think are
used in a lot of public schools uh
around the state um that um that would
be able toh to improve the um uh the
ability for for students that you know
with hearing loss to um to to hear
what's going on from the teacher but
also improve I guess the the experience
for other students as well and also and
also the experience of the um instructor
um that's a good question I believe
since it's outside of like building
construction um I'm not fully sure but I
believe Ada Federal um there's Federal
ADA requirements that require schools to
have so many um devices for students to
help with hearing um but but I'm not
positive on
that I believe the FM transmission that
many of the teachers have around their
waist and they transmit to the child in
the classroom that is done through Ida
it's a special ed uh supported item
actually Mr
chair yeah the um um many districts I
know we do it here in hopkington have
retrofitted classrooms um with these
systems and the um the speaker is not
does not reside with the student it's
actually built into the walls of the
classroom and um and if you haven't for
for anybody that that has experien
the difference between a classroom
without this and a classroom with this I
would really encourage um visiting a
local school or inquiring with the local
school because it's really very
impressive technology yeah that
technology is much different than we
used to do it and and then doing what
you're saying Dave is is yeah more
expensive but it's 100% better so are
there any other questions um well um
okay who's next on
here we have Linda Taylor with her hand
raised again she's that presented
before uh and then we have a new person
Gary Abbott with AGC AGC of New
Hampshire um they are not scheduled to
speak but I will put hasn't spoken okay
first
Abbott thank you uh chairman lad again
for the record my name's Gary Abbott I'm
the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I I like Amy signed up too
late on the website and uh uh I want to
talk about this bill as I had presented
it to
contractors uh the first point is where
this is located in the statute um if you
look at section 199 colon one it really
is about location and buildings not
building requirements as far as codes
for construction it sets up a new
chapter we think it's not in the right
place when you look at the state has its
own building
codes and we also have a building code
review board that handles amendments to
the code so we're not we we're not in
favor of the legislature adding sections
of code throughout the statutes uh this
will be confusing hard to find it won't
help with new
construction that's why the legislature
put together the New Hampshire uh
building code review board which through
the department of
safety so the code when it comes to ansy
codes and those they're updated with the
different versions of codes as they go
through and the legislature just
recently passed the legislation that
they would keep the codes one code back
and keep them updated so they would keep
up with the changing
regulations so we looked at this
strictly
as not the right place uh if you want to
talk about acoustic tiles that kind of
thing for classrooms if there needs to
be an amendment it needs to go through
the New Hampshire building code uh
review board that's where all the
amendments to different codes get placed
therefore the industry knows where to go
Architects know where to go to look at
any individual amendments so I'm not
here to talk about the need of the sound
quality in the classroom but I'm really
here to talk about the construction
regulation itself and the major point
for us is we are working really hard
with communities and municipalities that
have additional amendments to all be in
one place at the building code review
board so we're working on that
diligently with the legislature with the
building code Review Board in an effort
to do that now I represent commercial
contractors who build schools and so
that was our first when we looked at
this we think any amendment should go
through the building code review board
the second point is uh contractors
designers uh Architects they build based
on the current code uh the state
building code is the minimum code but
they can go above and beyond and the
towns can require above and beyond for
any of their schools for any uh
specialty items that they
want the the issue is there's a long
history of uh you know when we build a
school it's kind of it's grandfathered
to that date this legislation brings in
a standard that you've got to update all
the schools now HVAC systems can be very
expensive I'm sure my HVAC guys would
love to have to renovate all the schools
with new HVAC systems but I want to
point out that that could be a
problematic area and I don't know to
what fiscal impact that would have on
cities and towns so I want to bring that
to your attention and the other
compliance there is a Roman 4 that talks
in the bill about compliance uh in
writing with a lead architect usually
plans are done um the scope of larger
commercial projects are looked at even
through the fire mark Marshall's office
and others for Code Compliance but the
lead architect is designing it to that
current standard so it should be in
compliance with what is built but I
think you're going to end up with some
problems with if you're going to try to
update some of these older schools this
bill could become problematic so I'm not
opposed to it I just think the venue may
be the wrong place for this construction
kind of codes issue and with that I
would end my testimony and answer any
questions of the committee thank you Mr
EV uh I do have a question for you um I
know that uh schools are annually
annually visited by the fire marshal or
the the local fire chief that might have
that assigned Duty um when they're
looking at in terms of fire codes and
building
codes are is there anything dealing with
Acoustics that they look at as far as
that the building code review board has
approved and it's in code now um do we
have anything there and who has
oversight of that yeah I'm not so sure
the fire code looks at that unless it
had something to do with you know the
fire retardant of the acoustic panel
outside of that I think those reviews
are for safety purposes of exits and
entrances uh those kind of reviews I
think this gets into there's an awful
lot in the building codes acoustic
panels are one piece but there's an
awful lot of components um but you know
I I'm not in any way saying that there
shouldn't be some way for people to look
at it and maybe you're only talking one
or two classes in a school building uh I
just don't know the scope but when you
read this the bill really doesn't
clarify uh whether the renovation has to
be the total HVAC system or whether it's
a just classroom by
classroom thank you are there any
further
questions not see any hands thank you
thank you very
much no I don't oh uh Linda
Taylor okay I just didn't know we have a
few more movs left in this hearing so
one more that's even the second
round well she she took her hand down
yeah so I'm not sure if she had anything
else to say don't have anybody else in
the queue here so um what do we have in
terms of folks okay so uh I am assuming
that uh Mr Abbott was
opposed
um did he say not
opposed neutral okay so we have 15 in
support 15 support one oppos one oppos
two neutral two neutral and uh I think
we had five testified Barbara rep Shaw
is that correct four four so we have
four testified thank you
very I'm an off
day
okay okay with that we're gonna close
down to HB 267 and we will start the
next one in about seven minutes or
so give the tech person a chance for
some
coffee
oh
okay
okay okay we're going to go ahead now it
is 1:30 and we're ready to go ahead with
the next bill which is HB 441 requiring
Universal Declaration of Human Rights to
be placed in all public
schools the prime sponsor of that bill
is Ellen Reed is she present y I
believe I am
indeed
okay
hi there
hello welcome to
education thank you very much am am I
recognized
or go ahead thank you very much Mr chair
and honorable members of the education
committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 17 the
towns of New Market and new Fields um
and the bill I have here today for you
uh pretty simple one is the posting of
the UN Declaration of Human Rights in
schools um this is a bill that was
brought to me by another representative
who is a cross the a from me uh he the
idea was brought to him by one of his
constituents and um while at the time he
was not opposed to the idea I don't
think it was the kind of thing that he
saw as being um uh something that people
would expect him to put in so he asked
if I would put this in for him and I
said yes um and so and I spoke with this
constituent of his and the idea here
just for some background the United
Nations Declaration on human rights was
um formed in the wake of World War II
after the atrocities that the world had
experienced and it was the first time
this is in 1948 the first time ever that
uh the world um or even any substantial
amount of the world had put forth for
the idea that all human beings had a
standard by which that they should be
treated um and so when I spoke with this
constituent uh about why we should have
this posted in schools the idea was that
um this constituent certainly not him
only but I think many of us are dismayed
at the level of polarization and the
lack of Civility that has um kind of
beleaguered our our our culture these
recent years and um the thought was and
and I I connected with this particular
constituent because I actually teach
American government in college and first
day every semester I teach my students
the factors uh that lend stability
conditions for a stable democracy and
one of those factors is what we call
social cohesion and social cohesion is
the idea that we are more invested in
each other as members of our community
as fellow human beings than we are as
political Rivals so if I for example we
both go to the same like archery club or
we share you know we go to the same
church or whatever then I'm more
invested in you and can see you as
something that is kind of similar to me
and uh recognize that you have inherent
um worth and the the the right to be
respected just like I want to be and
because of that I am more invested in
you um than I am and you as a political
rival and so I'm invested in getting in
in moving past our differences um so the
idea of kind of teaching children at an
early stage that we all have these basic
human rights this is something that the
world has actually decided upon long ago
because of how poorly we have all
treated each other in the past past in
history um was something that really
spoke to me because this actually helps
us create stable
democracies so um and I believe that
that particular constituent is here to
talk more about um his feelings on the
matter um so I'll just I I'll put that
out there I won't read there's a it's a
list the actual declaration is a list of
30 articles it can be printed on one
large piece of paper um it's frequently
put on posters but each article is about
uh one or two sentences so it's not very
large or prohibitively large to to post
on one sheet of paper um there is a
obviously a cost a DI Minimus cost to
putting up a piece of paper in every
school um I I dare say that I could
probably pay for it out of my own pocket
which is actually really saying
something considering I'm just an
adjunct at a community college so um the
uh the member across the aisle from me
had offered the notion that perhaps it
could be amended to include the United
States Constitution and Declaration of
Independence um and I'm perfectly amable
with that these are things I obviously
Teach as well and then I'll just uh
close by saying that any time in
politics that we these days I guess that
we talk about anything related to the
United Nations I kind of feel like I
have to address something of an elephant
in the room which is the idea of the and
many of you might be familiar with the
agenda 21 conspiracy theory um that the
UN is I I don't want to get into into it
but there's like things about Illuminati
and taking over the world and and all of
those things and I just want to put that
out there that I was contacted by some
people who were very concerned that
something from the UN would be put into
our schools um because they were I guess
you know bought into some of these ideas
um by the way that theory has been
routin roundly uh debunked over and over
again but um I will say that the one
article that was pointed to me out to me
as problematic to the to these
individuals who are concerned about uh
the so-called Agenda 21 um was Article
29 where and I didn't read all of the
wonderful articles and I'll just pull
this up real fast so I can read it to
you article
states that nothing
uh uh sorry I lost my
place nothing uh no right these rights
and freedoms May in no case be exercised
contrary to the purposes and principles
of the United Nation United Nations this
was something that was of concern to the
person that I spoke with I did look into
what the purposes and principles of the
United Nations were um the four main
purposes of the UN is to keep peace
throughout the world to develop business
from the UN website to develop friendly
relations among nations to help Nations
work together to improve the lives of
poor people to conquer hunger disease
and illiteracy and to encourage respect
for each other's rights and freedoms and
to be a center for harmonizing the
actions of Nations to achieve these
goals uh the principles include and
there's you know a longer document but
equality the self-determination of
Nations
respect of Human Rights and fundamental
freedoms and the use of peaceful means
to resolve conflict so I just I I would
say that it is fine to say that none of
that should be interpreted to be in
contrary to those purposes um but I did
want to go ahead and and and kind of run
out in front of the um Agenda 21 style
arguments and with that I'm I'm happy to
take
questions thank you very much
representative Reed uh representa M
thank you Mr chair thank you repr Reed
for uh your measure I want to just
applaud your Civic activism and the
intent of the measure uh my one quick
question article three states quote
unquote everyone has the right to life
which I I have no problem with that uh
but do you think that could be problem
others it could be problematic for
others uh what would you say to that
well um I would say that our very
Declaration of indep dependence and
writings before that say that we have a
right to life so I presume and please do
interrupt me if I'm speaking out of turn
I presume you might be um
referencing uh the debate between
pro-choice and pro-life um arguments and
I from what I understand of that debate
that debate centers heavily around at
what stage of fetus is considered a
human person and so whatever that stage
is whatever people decide that is at
that point we all agree that a person
has a right to life so um I don't see a
problem with stating as we always have
in this country that we have a right to
life liberty and uh we say the pursuit
of happiness but uh Security in one's
person is is how the UN puts
it thank you thank you very much further
questions represent cordelli thank you
Mr chairman uh thank thank you
representative for being here this
afternoon um I'm just wondering
um with this declaration is there any um
enforcement or there are several places
that refer to laws whose laws are we
talking about um and for instance also
mentioned article nine No One S shall be
subjected to arbitrary arrest who
res thank you for the question um so
from my reading of this the UN as I just
said in its principles believes in the
serey of Nations and one of in one of
those principles also talks about the
non-interference with domestic matters
so um what I'm curious as to what part
you're talking about when it talks about
laws but um what I believe the overall
intention is saying is that laws should
not be written to uh take these human
rights away from people but beyond that
they don't interfere with with laws in
terms of the UN itself as a
charter member nations you know join the
UN and then are you know held to the the
charter principles so um there is the
concept of uh making sure that member
nations are accountable to that Charter
but um that's not really a law and as
far as arbitrary arrest um I mean you
could say this about so many of
basically everything that's written
whenever you're guaranteeing any kind of
right or anything like that there's a
lot of room for
interpretation but we all understand
arbitrary arrest is when um there was no
good reason to detain someone uh
possibly for example in a a a political
conflict where somebody might be
arresting their political opponents or
something like that but the idea is that
if someone gets um detained that there
is a good reason behind that um
reasonable suspicion that they committed
a crime or or what have you so I think
we can all agree I'm gonna go on a limb
and say I hope we can all agree that um
arbitrary arrest however you might
Define arbitrary but it certainly if
it's arbitrary that we should not be
tolerating
that thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question article
22 we have the right to affordable
housing medicine education and child
care enough money to live on and medical
health AR we now getting into socialism
and
communism well I mean it when you talk
so I'm gonna really try to hold back my
desire to to hop into my uh my teacher
mode about the difference between
communism and socialism these are
economic systems political systems and
you know communism is a very extreme but
you know it's never actually functioned
in the world socialism is a huge you
know big giant grayscale of diff many
many many different flavors and many of
those do exist in the world um but in
terms of the right so saying that
someone has a right or that you know
everyone should have XYZ is one thing
socialism as you might point out or any
other economic system whereby you try to
attempt to get there is is just what you
choose to get there right so if you can
form for example a capitalist structure
that ensures that everyone has basic uh
needs like you mentioned um then then
that would be fine too so saying that
everyone needs these things is different
from saying how do you go about
providing those things and that's up to
each Nation to
decide thank you very much uh represent
wood thank you Mr chairman represent
thank you for taking my question um I
was interested to read over this
document in preparation for this hearing
and of course is 1949 it says I think
1833 words so looking at the looking at
the
U legislation that talked about from
grades K to
12 uh I'm not sure the value of having
that particular document uh in grades K
through 12 uh as an entity however I did
have the opportunity to look at many
adapted ones for grade level pieces
which make much more sense and I was
looking at the as representative B just
talked
they his grade level one would be they
have it one phrase we all have a right
to affordable housing medicine education
child care enough M to live on in
medical health depending on the age of
the youngster in school so my question
is is the intent of this uh declaration
if approved to be grade level
appropriate versus or as your thinking
we're going to take that 1949 document
of 833 words and just plaster it on a
wall thank you very much for the
question and you are correct this has
been um adapted to all sorts of you know
child level reading um book form and you
name it
cartoons uh so certainly my intention it
would be completely in keeping with my
intention to post it in a Grade
appropriate format um like I said the
representative who approached me with
this was also talking about including
the Constitution the F the US
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence and I don't think we've
adapted those the same way this has been
adapted to a child level reading good
point but good point right so if we were
if we're gonna say let's put that out
there and and have it as like a formal
thing that's on the wall then uh you
know it makes sense to kind of leave it
in if those are in the original form to
leave this in its original form but I'm
not at all married to that and I think
it's totally fine to just convey the
meaning um to Children sure thank you
very much representative thank you Mr
chairman welcome are there any other
questions for the
representative representative Mo thank
you Mr chair thank you uh represent for
taking my question um personally I I uh
I see value to this at least in terms of
it being a educational historical
document um just speaking for myself so
I'm ask I'm wondering would you see a
possibility of this being amended so
that it would be in every school as
opposed to every classroom especially if
you might be paying for it if I
personally am uh so uh absolutely every
school is fine I think I thought that
the language said every school and
Civics Civic specifically Civics
classroom which would only be High
School uh or possibly mid Middle School
uh like so like one extra classroom in
high schools and middle schools uh but
yeah if it's just every school that is
intent thank you very thank you uh not
see any other other hands up right now
thank you very much representative and
we'll go to the next person who is okay
next speaker is anarie Banfield she's
been promoted uh go ahead
please okay thank you um my name is Anar
bfield and I'm an advocate for parental
rights and academic excellence and
education today I come here in strong
opposition to HB
441 uh first of all there's nothing
prohibiting a teacher or principal from
placing this document or any other
document in their school why does this
have to be a law and since there is no
mandate that the United States
Constitution be placed in all public
schools this certainly gives the
impression that the UN document is being
elevated the Declaration of Human Rights
is considered a common standard of
achievements for All Peoples and All
Nations but within their this document
there are goals that are Troublesome and
even by definition
tyrannical So within article 26 it says
Elementary education shall be
compulsory there is nothing in that
article that makes an exception for
homeschooling there's also a debate on
whether compulsory education is good
policy the US Supreme Court recognizes
that parents have the fundamental
fundamental Liber liberty interest for
the education of their children prior to
com compulsory education parents and
teachers worked together there was less
bureaucracy less red tape less Data
Tracking Beyond achievement much less
testing and more opportunity for an
education tailored to the child's needs
it's really up to the residents of New
Hampshire to determine support or
opposition to this type of education I
do have a major issue with article 29
where it states literally under number
two under number three these rights that
they list and freedoms May in no case be
exercised contrary to the purposes and
principles of the United Nations that's
quite a
statement this is in direct contrast to
the Declaration of Independence which
gave birth to our Republic and set forth
our unalienable rights to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness compare
article 29 to the adoption of the
Constitution of the United States which
built on the foundation principles set
forth in the Declaration of Independence
the constitutional republic is a
government of the People by the people
and for the people we are self-governed
and our rights do not come from the
United Nations if HB 441 passes what
does this say to the students attending
Public Schools what does it say to the
residents of New Hampshire what does it
say to the nation we may find Provisions
in this document that have some value
teachers are free to use this document
within their scope and sequence but if
you vote for HB 441 you are saying to
everyone that this document is worthy of
elevating to the point where we now want
this document in all schools I have
absolutely no problem with my children
reading this document but I want it
explained in reference to our founding
documents and that our individual rights
are inalienable not given to us by a
glob Global
organization this document is certainly
worthy of discussion and debate in a
civic's classroom however I would not
want that discussion led by an educator
I would want that discussion led by an
educator who understands our system of
government a republic that was set up to
place power in the hands of the people
and not a global organization that they
cannot
access so this is not about censoring
information this is about State Statute
and it elevating a document that with a
with with is almost like a direct attack
on our Liberty um you know just just
listening to you all asked questions of
the sponsor and having her discuss and
and debate this and and educate and talk
about that's good that's great for a
classroom and that's what I would want
it's it's it's not about hiding this
document or being afraid or any kind of
conspir iracy it's more about let's make
sure that if this document is introduced
to children in a school that it's done
in an educated way and a way where where
we're discussing and debating and
talking about and understanding what
some of these provisions mean and do is
it in contrast to what we have in our
own country um just finally a a few
other points I wanted to bring up you
know I was uh working the polls years
ago in Bedford and I was sitting there
with two students that were getting
ready to graduate from high school and I
asked them have you read the United
States Constitution before you graduate
from high school and their answer was no
can we please focus on on you know
making sure our kids are getting a
quality
education and and then let's move into
things like this uh I just I'm just so
afraid that this kind of state law makes
a statement and that's what that's what
concerns me but I do appre appreciate
the discussion I appreciate the
questions this is exactly what I would
expect in a civics class for my kids and
that's why I want it discussed but I
don't want I don't believe it needs to
be in law so I do thank you for taking
my testimony I do thank you for your
time and um I do ask that you vote
against hb5 or 441 thank you thank you
questions not seeing any thank you very
much
thank
you okay next we have
Carl from the school board uh I'm sorry
not the School Board Association the
school administrators
Association go ahead
please good afternoon members of uh
House Ed um thank you for letting me uh
testify this afternoon I find myself in
somewhat Uncharted Territory as I'm in
agreement with Miss Banfield but for
different reasons any SAA opposes uh
this legislation we certainly appreciate
the intent of the bill um but we are
opposed uh because it is a requirement
uh with no funding background or purpose
uh simply placing something in a school
does not necessarily equate uh to
meeting the intention of the sponsor and
one question I would ask is I wonder if
this bill were to pass would this be
considered a divisive concept under HB
257 thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you very much Carl are there any
questions of Carl lad School
administrators
Association not seeing any hands thank
you very much was there hand up
test okay yes I do see um where did
down oh here he goes he does wanna he
on
okay okay Mr Thomas I've promoted you
welcome to the education
committee
welcome
between there he is
okay is it will
Thomas
how about
this great well thank you thank you
chairman lad and members of the
education committee my name is William
Thomas I'm a uh retired
educator uh and uh I'm the one who asked
one of my representatives to sponsor
this bill and uh he uh very U was very
helpful and reach me out to
representative Reed and I thank her I
didn't realize how much of a commotion
this might cause uh yeah it's a a bill
that U we wanted posted to basically in
and I was thinking I was a high school
history teacher in some Civics uh trying
to uh inform students and I I sent my
written testimony I hope you receive
that uh I don't want to repeat what I've
said but uh to inform to educate and
possibly to inspire uh both students
teachers administrators parents to delve
deeper
into uh our Constitution which I taught
and in the latter stages of my career
when I received information from Amnesty
International actually a film short film
that went through all 30 Les of the
universal declaration we did compare uh
the Bill of Rights to the uh Universal
declaration as a matter of fact I have a
copy in front of me I'm going to run
through everything but like for example
Universal declaration article two
relates to the our 14th Amendment
Article Five relates to our Eighth
Amendment uh article 12 to our fourth
amendment on privacy uh article 18 First
Amendment religion uh so I I understand
the concerns of of some of the folks who
oppose this bill which I of course do
support uh but the the thing to recall
also is that the universal Declaration
of Human Rights uh which was adopted by
the way uh 1948 on December 10th and
incidentally the uh the actual uh
Charter which was signed in s Francisco
on June
26 1945 right before the end of World
War II actually uh I went to a
convention there in that Hall that
Auditorium uh where that document was
signed so I I have a kind of a close
Affinity to that but anyway uh uh
representative Reed mentioned the fact
that um I think she mentioned the League
of Nations was a failure uh the U
Holocaust were where uh uh millions of
people were were killed including uh you
know Gypsies and
homosexuals and political dissidents Etc
um so they came together in San
Francisco in
1945 and signed that that initial
document and then on December 10th
1948 uh the general assembly did
announce the vote uh in favor and
ification including the United States uh
of the universal declaration which most
importantly to recall is not a treaty it
is not binding on any country uh what is
binding however are the Proto the
covenants and the conventions and the um
the protocols to these conventions and
Covenants of the 18 that I know of I've
researched the United States has signed
and ratified but five uh 13 that we have
not uh
ratified and so I I I think that maybe
they're reading too much into this yeah
and I think age appropriate uh by the
way representative Reed if you're
listening we would help py my other
organization called Veterans for peace
uh we were thinking of laminating them
uh yeah and and the fact that they're
there may stimulate people act as a
catalyst to inquire well what is this
I'm reading this uh but yeah in the
classroom where it should be taught I
think in terms of of what what this
country has stood for or says it stands
for uh human rights among other things
by the way Franklin Roosevelt in January
1941 if you haven't read it I recommend
it highly the for freedom
speech uh which uh uh president
Rosevelt spoke of a
unified uh world and a precursor of the
United Nations so anyway I would U be
happy to take any uh any questions if
I'm able to answer them are there any
Thomas not seeing hands thank you very
much thank
you we do have um representative Reed
with her hand raised I don't know if you
want to call on her again
no okay
okay all right I guess that's it then
um we do you want the totals on can we
have the totals please uh 17 support 17
and support 22 opposed 22 opposed zero
neutral zero neutral and 1 two three
four uh testifying five
testifying thank you very much so with
that we will close on HD
441 and we're opening now we're going
into
h69 all put to the display the national
schools
okay do we have represent true pres we
do representative true welcome to
education
case you
there here he comes there good I'll set
now yeah we can hear you sorry about
that thank you uh good afternoon Mr
chair and members of the education
committee for the record I am
representative Chris true Rockingham
District 4 comprising the town of auin
Chester and Sandown thank you very much
for allowing me to speak on house bills
69 and act relative to the display of
the national motto in schools please
allow me to start by saying those four
words you all want to
hear I will be
brief New Hampshire is a Dylan rule
state basically dlan's rule says that
unless a political subdivision has been
specifically granted The Authority it
does not have the authority to
act House Bill 69 is enabling
legislation it is granting a school the
authority to display the national
modotto of the United States of America
in school
buildings if schools if a school does
not have the funds to provide the
durable poster or frame copy of the
national model a school May accept
non-public funds or in-kind
contributions so that the national model
can be displayed in the
school in our recent history there have
been many attempts to have the national
model removed from government buildings
and even the US
currency in 2018 the 8th Circuit Court
ruled that the national modotto on US
currency was not unconstitutional and in
29 2019 the US Supreme Court rejected
the suit that was claiming the national
model and 's currency was
unconstitutional since since there are
groups in the United States that have
the time and the financial backing to
bring suit perhaps the mere threat of a
lawsuit against a school for posting the
national model would be enough to stop a
school from displaying the national
model for fear of a costly court case
that is why this bill would protect our
schools from any lawsuits if the
displaying of our country's National
modotto were to be challenged in court
the Office of the Attorney General of
New Hampshire would defend the school in
the court Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you very much for your
time and your
consideration thank you very much
representative true are there any
representative representative Woodcock
representative Woodcock thank you uh
representative lad and representative
Tru thank you for taking my question I
recall hearing you speak last year on
this I think it was 1148 or 1140 ser
iies bill um if I recall correctly and
and the national model we're talking
about which you didn't say I thought
those are the four words you're going to
say when you started the dialogue um is
In God We Trust which I have uh a great
belief that being said however many
others who attend school do not happen
to have the same belief that I do or
that you may have and I wonder why we
would we would uh put uh
this uh ideology in all of our schools
or allow School building to be used for
that by as a law uh when we have such a
diverse population of folks that come to
the schools that are believers or not
Believers why should we have just one
sec belief there please it's my
question thank you for the question
um the national model is in all on all
our currency it is simply what it is
it's the National model of our country
um many courts especially the eth
Circuit Court which I think is in St
Louis for saying that it is not uh an
infringement upon Congress you make no
law it is simply uh uh the national
model has been since uh 1955 I read I
read nothing more into those four words
then it is the motto of our
country followup representative lad
right thank you well repres true
understand it's not an
infringement um but though my question
was why should we put those four words
of which I happen to be a strong
believer why should we put those four
words in our school buildings um when it
may uh disenfranchise many of the
youngsters and students to come and
faculty to come into that building why
would we uh identify a particular
belief I I don't care if it's on money I
wish I had more of it but that's not the
point uh the circuit courts have ruled
it is uh it is not uh about a belief it
is simply the national modotto um I
believe the uh the argument being made
was the argument that was made by the
into the E circuit court that some
people are could be offended by the
national model because it has the word
God in it and the that's what the that's
what the eth Circuit Court
rejected um that that it was not un
unconstitutional to have the word God in
a national model since since uh
1955 thank you repres TR he didn't
answer the question but thank you thank
you representative ladc are there
further questions have represent true
represent thank you Mr chair uh
true I'd like to follow up on
representative woodcock's uh question
with my own forward question uh which is
Live Free or Die which is our state
model for Words which is on our state
license plate but my question is do you
do you see this National
model uh requirement is analogous uh
similar to the state model requirement
where we have that on state license
plates and
elsewhere um
all all states well well Most states
that I know of they all have their
individual State model or whatever
phrase they're going to put on their
license plates
um I I believe it was a few years ago uh
there was there was a bill in the house
uh to do away with the state motto
because they thought it was too
violent
um and and to that I I say the same
thing about the national
modotto it is the state motto is not a
motto thank you are there further
questions not seeing any hands thank you
very much representa TR thank you Mr
chair
welcome have anybody
else uh no I do not see any other hands
raised and
no one has signed to testify other than
that
true okay so we're gonna close this
hearing down but get the
number we have Carl AD school
administrator associ just raise his
hand almost like he went through a
yellow
light go ahead Mr lad okay Carl you're
up on Deck here sorry Mr chairman um I
thought I had signed up to to speak um I
think
um I I hesitate to insert myself into
this type of uh discussion but I I I
think it's important the phrase In God
We Trust isn't something that was
conjured up by the founders I was first
used on a coin uh by the North in the
Civil War and it wasn't until 1956
during the Red Scare um when our country
wanted to strike a blow against quote
unquote Godless communism in the Soviet
Union that the bill passed President
Eisenhower did sign it um and that
phrase replaced the much more inclusive
urbus Unum which used to be on our
currency uh out of many one um which had
served as our national motto since
1782 um when we say that the phrase In
God We Trust isn't really religious um I
I don't think that that's exactly
accurate um it's obviously a religious
phrase uh it's one that puts the
government in the position of taking a
stand on theology the phrase asserts
that there is one God not five not 20
not no God and it says you should trust
in this God the implication is that this
is what Real Americans do if you choose
not to are these people to be considered
suspect or
unpatriotic when we have signs or
posters commun communicating this kind
of statement posted in public schools
and put in front of our most
impressionable youngsters the message is
not subtle the students are being told
that their Public School A
government-run institution wants them to
believe in and indeed trust in God for
parents and children who don't accept
that view um or even the existence of
God uh the harm is real and it can be
palpable for those families um this this
legislation could open school districts
to unnecessary Division and litigation
which the sponsors are clearly expecting
based on the language in lines 8 through
10 uh we respectfully oppose to this
bill while we certainly understand the
intent and appreciate the passion of the
sponsors uh we oppose the bill based on
those concerns thank you Mr chairman for
letting me uh jump in morning welcome
are there any questions for the school
administrators
Association
much so yep so uh we had I
guess uh three support three in support
26 opposed 26 opposed zero neutral zero
neutral and two testifying and two
testifying
uh we had Chris true uh R true and Mr
L thank you very much we are closing the
69 and
uh 230s when we go into the next
here got about 15 minutes take a break
out
take I was studying
kids
chairman
lad I just I've been appointed to the um
advisory Council for Career and
spech
speech I've I've I spoke with Eric and
I'm I'm very excited about it I think
you'll enjoy that yeah well I I like
career in technical education and
actually pushed it when I was in a
middle school guidance counselor all the
time so I'm I'm really happy to be on
this I think their next meeting is on
the 8th of March yep I I just got an
email with the agenda and the I think
the zoom is on it too well the agenda
and the minutes from last month we'll
get the zoom so it's Monday yes always
enjoy patri is that if you could they
always look for legislative updates on
what we're doing in terms of CTE and the
sense
okay yeah and and if you ever need some
help on that i' I'd love to help you out
on that because why you want
it I don't know if I stay on that I I
don't even know all the commissions I'm
on I thought he told me you were on it
well if you get an email today you'll
Eric I can't recall whether I'm on that
or not anymore I enjoy the people you'll
enjoy some of the directors there good
heads I I thought Eric told me that you
but
I'm looking forward to
pack Patricia you out there still I
think the person that that's on it now
that's taking my spot Karen
lber you know
Karen just in passing but yes she she um
on the board up in North Conway Conway C
there she's very active I think you'll
enjoy working I just didn't have any
more time to give
it so get know Karen she's a really neat
jingle
Tru
[Music]
truck I can't not I just had it here in
yeah public higher education get to
Afghanistan
emirats
I don't know Chuck's appointed anybody
yet or not
okay just that's another one
that's uh seeing that there's so many
big issues out there in postsecondary
that's why we're Jump Ahead ourselves
the
first
Mary
no I not I'll give you my notes after
finish
welome
are
Amy is that
her Amy catling I see and then there's a
phone
number Mary
[Music]
bill y you're you're down here
list
hand yep you ready oh yeah ready to
rumble
number
Bey Wilson School Board oh she's just
raising her hand
for
me
great okay I think we're going to go
ahead here H for all those out in
the world of
technology we have a bill right now uh
HB 581 relative to the burden of proof
and special education
hearings uh representative Cordell
you're the prime sponsor of the bill are
you ready to present it to us I am fine
you have you have the floor thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you uh fellow
committee members uh for the record I'm
Glen cordelli representing tuon buror
molten bur and sandwich in the beautiful
Lakes
Region individuals with disabilities
Education Act idea and the intent of Ida
is an important factor here I believe it
the intent to provide children with
disabilities the same opportunity for
Education as those students who do not
have a
disability another piece of this
discussion is the US Supreme Court case
schaer versus whest in
2005 the parents of Brian schaer who had
learning disabilities sued their local
Maryland school district over a proposed
IEP The District Court ruled for the
schafers but the fourth cir fourth
Circuit Court reversed that decision I
should mention that the uh schafers got
services from the district only after
the Court ruled for the
Shavers because Ida is silent on the
burden of proof the fourth circuit held
that the general rule that the party
initiating the suit Bears the burden
should be applied that set the stage for
the US Supreme Court where it became an
interesting
discussion the court majority agreed
that the party seeking relief should
bear the burden but the court declined
to address the question of whether
States on their own could adopt
legislation or regulations assigning the
burden to the school
district in the majority opinion Justice
okono wrote we need not decide this
issue today Justice Brier contends that
the allocation of the burden ought to be
left entirely up to the state but
neither party made that argument before
this court we therefore declin to
address
it so in that Supreme Court case nine
States filed briefs supporting the idea
that the burden should fall on the
district since that decision in
2005 number of States including
Connecticut New York New Jersey have
passed similar uh laws to HB
581 let me touch on one detail in the
bill on lines three and four you will
note that the the terms burden approv
Pro and burden excuse me burden of
production and burden of
persuasion uh burden of proof
encompasses both these
principles as Justice OK Conor wrote the
term burden of burden of proof is
slippery in terms of family legal terms
part of the confusion surrounding the
term arises from the fact that the
concept en encompasses both these
distinct burdens persu
and
production production meaning that you
must offer evidence to be allowed to
proceed and persuasion meaning that you
have to convince of the existence of
facts to Prevail in the
case that is why in HB 581 we assigned
both burdens to the school district to
make sure that there was no
confusion and why should we place the
burden of proof on districts I'll start
with a quote from the late Justice
Ginsburg and her descent in this Supreme
Court case uh she cited the prior fourth
circuit court and mentioning that the
party with the bigger guns but she she
went on to write that they have better
access to information greater expertise
and an affirmative obligation to provide
the contestant services policy
considerations convenience and fairness
I think it plain point in the same
direction
their collectively warrants a rule
requiring the school district in due
process hearings to explain persuasively
why it's proposed IEP satisfies Ida
standards I believe that Justice
Ginsburg was right parents don't have
the resources to take on a school
district it can be very expensive to
hire a lawyer parents don't have the
legal resources document or information
that a school district does they don't
have the ability to interview School
staff before a hearing the parents are
at a disadvantage and that is why we
have so few de due process hearings uh
we've had written testimony from a
number of people said saying you why why
do I want to go to this expense when I'm
um I don't have the resources to Prevail
and I would like to comment on um other
written testimony that we received
um three points if I could um in the
testimony it states imposing the burden
of production on school districts is bad
policy because it will unnecessarily
prolong special ad
hearings putting the burden of
production on parents does not prolong
hearings probably not because they don't
have the resources to provide all the
background information the lawyers and
the testimony that uh that the school
district
does
secondly HB
581 will increase local costs while no
offering no additional State funding to
cover the costs so again here we raised
the boogeyman of increased local
costs but they refuse again to talk
about the kids and what about the human
costs we talk about the monetary costs
but what about the human cost in this
case special uh needs children and
thirdly uh it is difficult to it is
already difficult for school districts
to Prevail at special edit hearings oh
really hearing officers naturally
sympath sympathize with students who
have disabilities and with their
parents sometimes hearing officers
Overlook that public resources are
finite when a district spends more money
on one student it must raise taxes or
cut programs for other
children hearing officers do not decide
the facts on decide the case on facts
but on emotions about who they feel
sorry
for um maybe someone from the Department
could comment on that but troubling to
me the district has finite resources
what about parents what about their
resources there's no there's no
equivalency here it's out outrageous in
my opinion that statement is one of the
most troubling that I've heard in in a
long
time so this is really about a matter of
fairness it's fairness for parents and
fairness for children with children with
disabilities they need to have a Level
Playing Field when they go to a deep due
process hearing and HB 581 will provide
them with that Level Playing Field thank
you Mr chairman thank you very much are
there questions for representative
cordelli rep Miler rep Miler thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
cordelli for taking my question so if
this bill were to become
law can you explain how it would change
things what what would how how it would
look different than what we currently
have um right now uh when a parent U
files for a due process hearing it is a
uh the burden of proof the burden of
production and persuasion is on the
parent they must convince the hearing
officer that the proposed IEP does not
meet the child's needs does not comply
with h
idea um with 581 the burden of proof
would be on the school district they
have the resources to provide uh the
information um that the parents do not
um and I think that that is why it
levels the
playing a followup
please and and the who is the hearing
offer officer in this m c um I believe
that they are appointed by the
Department of
Education so if I may then uh the an
independent person comes in in this
hearing under this law and rather as I
understand it rather than having the
parent
having to provide whatever
documentation uh medical records uh
whatever they might be the school
district then would basic would
basically switch at that point in time
where the school district would then
have to basically provide that burden
rather than the parent is that correct
right they would have to Pro they would
have to convince the uh hearing officer
that um their proposed uh services um
plan um does meet the needs of the child
rather than the other way around okay
thank you very much for that
clarification I appreciate that thank
you uh are there further questions for
representa
cordelli represent
wood thank you representative lad and
thank you representative cell for just
taking my question I have I have two
questions the first one is probably the
easier the two I guess how how do you
how are they going to measure
preponderance what does that actually
mean
um maybe I'll leave that uh if there's a
lawyer here as to the termination of the
prance of evidence but I think it's the
bulk of the prance um be more than
50% but U I'll really leave that to a
please so the the school district could
create this as you said volume of
production wouldn't that be a
preponderance of
data um it's production but it's not
necessarily
persuasion so and final final question
if I may Mr chair how how does how does
this process that you're
recommending differ from the current
special ed complaint process
now um when there's a special a
complaint um there are several steps
that can be um uh initiated by a parent
including mediation due process is the
uh the final step um and that's the
existing process um I'm not changing
that process at all I'm just changing in
a due process hearing um who has to
person
Pro just the one last final so are you
suggesting that there's not a
difference
of a difference between the due process
hearing and a special ed complaint
hearing there is there is um this is uh
processing thank you thank you Mr for CH
M you're welcome are there any H further
questions for representative
cordelli rep represent
Mullen thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh representative of cordelli so o okay
not to be obtuse here but tell me if
I've got this right as the law is
written right now if a parent takes a
school district to doe process the
parent has to go in and produce all the
physical evidence and the
persuasion to convince the hearing
officer that the school is not doing
enough or not meeting the needs of the
child I'm sorry that's the way it is
right now right whoever files the
complaint is responsible all right so in
the case of a parent thinking that the
school isn't doing enough then the
parent would have to come up with the
argument and all the evidence but if we
were to adopt this and a parent filed
for due process and said the school's
not doing enough then then what this
would do is put the school in the
position of having to go in and say we
are doing enough here's all of this
evidence and here's the
persuasion that indicates that we're
doing enough they would have to come up
with the information to defend
themselves yes okay all right thank you
just making sure I I I I wasn't chasing
my own tail
here thank you uh further
questions
not see any hands here or there thank
you very much represent cordelli okay
next speaker is Mary Gibbon Stevens and
I promoted her go ahead and welcome to
education thank you um so yes my name is
Mary Stevens I'm an attorney I practice
with the law firm in KY Maine and I've
been practicing law for over 30 years in
different roles as in child advocacy and
one uh part of my ad advocacy has been
in protecting the educational rights of
disabled children and their parents
under idea that representative cordelli
was just mentioning um and the purpose
of idea is to ensure that disabled
children are provided with what we call
well what the statute says is a free and
appropriate education a free and
appropriate public education that we
refer to as fate that's the acronym that
we use um and the purpose is also so
that uh disabled children can achieve
further education employment and
independent living so basically in the
big picture the purpose is to allow
children and and to um to have states
spend the money on children's education
when they're young so that when they
finish their education their secondary
education they can become uh taxpayers
and fully uh you know um members of
society and our and contributing members
of our communities so but like many laws
while idea gives parents and children
with disabilities um several rights um
it does not always uh the intent is not
always played out in reality in
practice and parents really do I want to
say that I Echo 100% from my you know
day-to-day experience what
representative cordelli has described
and explained I second it completely um
so parents of disabled children often
face an uphill battle regarding their
children's education they in addition to
caring for their children they have to
learn all they can about their child's
disability and they have to become
experts not only about their own
individual children but about the
condition or conditions that impact
their development then they have to
advocate for them to receive an
appropriate education now when parents
are treated as equal members of the team
the system can actually work very well
but unfortunately there are many times
when parents are not viewed as experts
at the table and they're not treated as
equal members of the team and when that
happens and parents assert that the
school is not providing their child with
Fae they can request a due process
hearing as you heard and this hearing is
intended to be an efficient
administrative review it is not intended
to be lengthy litigation but the truth
is it's a complicated and difficult
legal process the federal and state laws
and regulations are very very long and
their dense now New Hampshire has a
parent friendly Guide to the New
Hampshire special education regulations
the parent friendly guide is 282 pages
long that just gives you an idea that in
addition to all the caregiving and other
responsibilities parents have they have
to familiarize themselves with hundreds
of pages of detailed legal language in
order to assert their child's right to
an education and even when they get that
understanding they're often still at it
at a disadvantage and I want to um
respond a little bit to the questions
that were raised earlier if you think
about you know Lady Justice the scales
of Justice the the woman with the
blindfold and holding the scales of
Justice what we're talking about is who
has to
prove the the Tipping the scales of the
justice and there uh the and there was a
question about preponderance of the
evidence that's what it is like who like
are does the evidence lean on one side
or the other and so who has the burden
of proving that in reality the process
is not going to be any different because
as uh representative cordelli said there
are some cases in which a district will
initiate the due process hearing in that
case the district has the burden of
proof in any of these cases both sides
produce the evidence that they want to
produce whether you are asserting the
case or whether you're defending the
case you are asserting the same evidence
but the reason that this is so important
and truly is leveling the playing field
is for the uh reasons that uh that
representative cordelli mentioned that
um Justice Ginsburg had mentioned in her
uh descent the school is the holder of
the information and the evidence
regarding the child's education parents
do not know what happens at school on a
day-to-day basis now it's not unusual I
will tell you for teachers and other
staff members to give parents
information off the Record and it's
understandable that the same people are
then unwilling to speak up in a way that
would impact their employment this is a
reality that happens sometimes and
parents often have to fight with schools
to obtain documents and other evidence
and even after several requests all the
information may not be provided and
since the school is the holder of the
evidence the school should bear the
burden of proof at Heering and in order
for parents to prove that their children
did not receive fape from the school
district they usually need the testimony
of one or more expert Witnesses and the
schools have a variety of experts on
staff calling those experts to testify
may not call uh may not cost the school
district extra money but parents have to
find and retain experts at their own
expense and Shifting the burden of proof
uh from the school uh I mean from the
parents to the school May alleviate some
of the expenses incurred by the parents
pursuing due process because they don't
have that hurdle quite as high a hurdle
to prove they still need to convince the
the hearing officer there're still the
two sides of the argument but they don't
have that that such a high hurdle
finally it is the school that has the
obligation to provide fate for the the
child parents have their own
responsibilities but when it comes to
educating a disabled child the duty
rests squarely upon the school district
the school district has the obligation
to educate so the school district should
have the burden of proving it has done
so when parents raise a challenge so
this bill will help to protect the
rights of the most vulnerable members of
our society disabled children and I urge
you to uh pass and approve and support
this bill and I'm willing to take any
questions thank you very much uh St uh
are there any
questions from the committee represent
Miler uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh Miss Stevens for taking my
question I I have I have two uh
questions really uh one in your
experience um how what percent of the
um issues that you deal with are
resolved in mediation that's the first
question well um most are you know very
most are either resolved at the IEP
process in the schools or through um
mediation you know it's um going to doe
process I going to tell you it is an
extreme burden on parents it's a lot of
work it is it is not the the efficient
hearing that is intended and so we only
go to due process as a last resort
honestly so so so you would say you're I
think you answer the first question that
most get resolved either through the IEP
process or through a mediation process
correct okay so the second question is
this is that what is
the what's the problem with the school
districts as relates to their position
typically is it because there are they
are fearful of the potential cost that
might be incurred here um is and so I'm
just kind of wondering what your
experience has been in dealing with the
school district's position when they go
to uh when they go to the due process
Harry when they go to Due Process um
when we're at that point there's been
you know a breakdown usually of trust
between the parents and the district I
mean it's always you know Ida okay um is
it has never been fully funded that's a
that's a big problem so there are these
you know mandates coming from the
federal government to the states and
they're never full it's never been fully
funded so it all come it often comes
down to money even though it's not
supposed to come down to money so it's
always the elephant in the room you
can't say the school district is you
know is not supposed to say we can't do
that because we can't afford it they're
supposed to do whatever the child needs
but the reality is and I so yeah so that
your the statement you said about the
breakdown in trust obviously is key the
final thing is is um there's been some
concern about frivolous cases going
forward If This Were to shift in in the
burden of proof what's your what's your
sense of that comment I honestly
honestly cannot see that happening I
mean because if if parents I mean it's
still it's not like a parent can just um
you don't think of any lawsuit right you
if if a parent just makes an accusation
against a school district with nothing
to back it
up they still have to are they gonna are
they gonna hire an attorney if they're
not going to hire an ATT I mean attorney
has their we have our ethical obligation
to not pursue frivolous cases right so
they have to go through that so if
they're going to do it on their own it's
still so much work they still have to
get the documents they still have to get
experts they still have to produce
Witnesses I I just don't see that being
a realistic thing it is not a pleasant
experience for parents okay thank you
thank you very much for your input thank
you very much you're welcome thank you
for your
questions Miss Stevens I have a question
under current law the way it is right
now are there various organizations or
groups out there with the funding
available for parents to help pursue a
case like this or is it a result of
parents not having the these Monies to
help cost out this horrible situation so
they're stopping uh are there agencies
out there are there funding sources are
there advocacy groups that are willing
to take something like this forward
there are there are legal aid um so what
I what I have found in my practice is
that um it it's so it's a it's a very
expensive thing for a small Law Firm
like myself you know it's very expensive
it takes a lot of time what I find is
that either parents can um go to a law
firm that you know requires like tens of
thousands you know like
$30,000 upfront to to litigate a due
process matter or they can go to a legal
aid um you know legal aid providers that
can do it but they of course um then you
have income requ requirements and then
they're really booked and can only take
certain cases and then there's you know
disability rights and they'll do it but
again they're um they're overbooked and
can't take all the cases and so it's the
sort of um it's the um middle class
families that have a hard time with this
that can't really afford
$30,000 to you know pay for this and so
um
there is a fee shifting provision in
idea where if parents Prevail then um
they the the school district um has to
pay their attorney fees but that's after
you go through a whole hearing so
sometimes we're able to negotiate and
get some attorney's fees paid in
mediation but it's always you know
nickel and dimed and then um but other
things are not like expert Witnesses are
not paid for by uh the school District
even if the parents Prevail so they
still have um often very you know high
costs and then what happens is that you
know we I mean just to be frank you know
we end up not being paid our full price
we you know our full fees we cut it and
you know in our effort to try to resolve
these matters so um but I have not I'm
not familiar with any organization I
know I have one client now who is trying
to get funding from some organizations
that help support her disabled child but
I have not seen that myself any
organizations that have been able to
fund um this and you know like it's very
costly and so sometimes I mean I'll be
perfectly Frank with you sometimes it's
much better for parents to put their
money towards supplementing the
education and put it towards a tutor or
put it towards another person that's
giving Direct Services to their child
instead of paying me to try to assert
their right under the law I mean that is
that is not an unusual conversation for
me to have with
clients one follow what you just said so
a parent goes through the IEP process
working in the IEP and nothing gets
resolved there they go to mediation
nothing's resolved there how long does
the due process take to get that
concluded and what happens to the
student in the room so it's um it's
supposed to be conclud uh concluded very
quickly sometimes it does get continued
but that's only by um by agreement so
that's not that's typically not a
problem sometimes things happen with
people's schedules and you know and that
that does happen but if a child is in a
situation where there really needs to be
um an um you know a decision made
quickly then it needs to be made within
30 days and then the hearing officer H
sorry I don't have all the D Times
Really committed to memory the days
because every State's a little different
but um it has to be very quickly you
know has to be very quick turnaround so
that's that part is fine thank you very
much are there any further questions
Stevens repres you have your hand up yes
sir yes Mr
chairman uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking the question
um seems from what I'm hearing that a
lot of this is b a lot of the concern
here um is based on and probably fairly
so on unequal economic
resources so District resources versus a
families
resources um and an unequal uh perhaps
opportunity or uh ability or the time to
master and gain sort of control over uh
large amounts of both data uh but also
as you said the parents the friendly
guide for parents that's well over 200
pages long so given all of that I'm
still at I'm still trying to figure out
how does changing the burden solve those
things so it it just
will we go into
um we go into a hearing with the
school having to um not just poke holes
in our case and say you didn't prove it
and so again it's like the you know if
it's the the even like you just um they
ha they have to prove they have to have
that that heavier piece of the of the
scales than than we do so it
um it's a hearing officer can say well
parents I here you know yes you you've
established this this and this but you
didn't prove that it's at that level so
it's it's a it's a hurdle I keep using
that word hurdle but that's what it
feels like you know it's like a
something you have to overcome at the
hearing and so it does um it just helps
to level the playing field it doesn't
change who has access to the information
and so forth but it just makes it more
the other thing that that just I guess
is still uh a little Troublesome to me
maybe uh and I don't know I don't know
where I stand on this but um you know
normally in our system I believe you
know the idea is that this is what at
least what I've been taught um is that
you're innocent until proven
guilty but in this case it would be kind
of the district is guilty unless they
can prove they're
innocent
like if you're it's more like that you
know the state has the OB has the burden
of proof and a criminal matter because
you know it's the state to prove that
and you know obviously the the burden of
proof is higher it's beyond a reasonable
doubt in a criminal matter but it's
um
it's who who has the the access um to
the information the evidence the
witnesses and all of that you know and
it's really so the whole idea you have
to get back to the purpose of idea you
know it's it really isn't supposed to be
this this uh
confrontational parent V
school thing it's supposed to be and the
department of Ed for the state is
supposed to be overseeing this it's
supposed to be that that that you know
the kids have rights and that their
rights are being protected and and um
and so the school just comes in and said
this is what we're doing and this is why
we're doing it and this is um enough and
you know it's um schools and
superintendents and teachers have a lot
of
um you know trust from the hearing
officers I'd say or whatever the right
word is
right I guess I I guess my concern or
the thing that sort of sticks with me
and even just following with what you
just said if if if I'm suing the
state because I believe the state is
abridging my rights the burden lies with
me but in this case it sounds like the
burden the parent or whomever files is
saying you are bridging my the child's
rights but the burden lies with the
state or the district I'm sorry um the
burden lies with the state of the
district in this case to say no actually
we're not
um so again it it seems I don't to me it
just seems to reverse uh what is the
norm I'm not saying that that's that's
you know problematic I'm just trying to
get my head around this that's all well
that's why you know the the Supreme
Court defaulted to that and said you
know we're it's the party bringing the
action has the burden of proof so when
the school district brings the due
process they have the burden of proof
but you just think of like even access
to you know access to evidence access to
Witnesses it's it's a unique situation
and it um because of what's involved um
and who's involved it requires a unique
approach my opinion okay thank you thank
you very much thank you very much uh
represent
Tanner thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question Miss Stevens
um I would ass is am I making a correct
assumption that the cases that go to Due
Process are are not just over a tutor or
um you know minor thing in the IEP that
when it goes to Due Process the stakes
are pretty
high sometimes
um sometimes it involves you know like
private like placement at a private
school you know special purpose private
school but sometimes
it's um but yeah you know has to be cost
efficient I guess for both parties so
the so the mediation is because I know a
lot of schools have been trying to um
you know beef up for lack of better
words they're inhouse special education
services right right and providers in
order to keep the child in the least
restrictive environment and also to keep
them within District um is this where a
lot of the due process problems come
arise well you know certainly some but
not not all sometimes it's just you know
in in my professional opinion it's when
there's um a disconnect between the
parents understanding of their child's
disability and needs and the school's
understanding of the of the needs and
then I think schools have to make
decisions they um based on budgets even
though that's not supposed to be part of
it that's the reality you know and you
can't blame them but that's the reality
but um often it's just when parents and
then when parents are really advocating
strongly sometimes school districts just
they they just won't listen to them I
mean that's the reality and you know I
know we all support schools and
everything but that is the reality of it
happens thank you thank you thank you
very much rep Woodcock do you have a
question just one thank you Mr chairman
P Stevens thank you for taking my
question and I feel like representative
Le I'm sort of have time hard time
getting head on
this in in your practice in this
particular type of a
case can you give me a ballpark on
percentage where the where the uh
results not typically land uh the parent
wins 70% of the time 30% of the time
schools 602 just where is that distrib
ution just ballpark if you may I think
um schools generally win when it goes to
hearing and schools if they will settle
if they think that they're going to lose
so yeah no I think that um parents lose
more than they win when it goes to
hearing my experience it's absolutely
true okay thank you thank you attorney
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much uh M St are there further questions
Stevens go ahead thank you she very much
I was just gonna say Thank you Mr chair
thank you for having me I thought you
ask yourself a
[Music]
question thank you very much okay so
um Mora Ryan has joined
yep go ahead Miss Ryan can you hear
me okay thank you just checking if you
hear a lot of wind it's because it's
very windy and hopefully hopefully my
house will not blow
away um my name is Mora Ryan and I'm
here to speak to you regarding HB
581 um I am a member of the sock
committee and I'm also the head of a
parent advocacy group um and I am here
speaking as a private individual and a
person who has gone through due process
personally um HB 581 would shift the
burden of proof from parents to schools
and do class hearings this bill is
critically important to students with
disabilities who are struggling to
access an appropriate appropriate
education as a parent I've Had The
Misfortune to go through facilitated IEP
meetings State complaints mediation and
due process these processes are
inherently biased and unfair here are
some of the reasons why facilitated IEP
meetings don't involve a facilitator who
guides the conversation to move forward
as a result the facilitator will repeat
what each person has said which is not
productive in state complaints the
parent as the filer is required to
submit everything that they send to the
investigator to the school as well but
the school is not required to send their
information to the parent who is given
no opportunity to refute or present
additional evidence to address that um
if you're familiar with due process that
would be a violation of due process that
would not be something that would be
acceptable in a court of law um in
addition school districts have the use
of attorneys whereas parents do not last
there's due process due process is an
unfair bias and one-sided system why
school districts have access to all of
the students records and can observe the
student in the school parents have been
denied the ability to conduct
observations within with their own
evaluators even though they have that
right by law I have a parent who's
preparing to file for due process right
now she requested a complete set of
records for her child she received
approximately 40 pages for the students
10 plus years in school there's no way
these records are that limited in my due
process say the school turned over no
current records and special education
records that were over 3 years old if
you're familiar with due process you can
only go back two years so I did not
receive any records that would assist me
with my due process claim exhibits are
exchanged five days prior to due process
and if the school has put in an exhibit
that the parent wants to challenge with
new evidence it is virtually impossible
to get it entered into the record in my
D process we were not able to get any
Discovery or use any exits and had to
rely completely on what the school gave
us
they started they they slanted things
from the records and they misinterpreted
them to suit their purposes I was not
permitted to hear all of the testimony
that the school district gave but the
school Lea was able to hear all I I was
not permitted to hear all the testimony
that was rendered but was able to hear
all my testimony plus all of her
employees testimony in addition the
testimony of the of two witnesses went
missing the evaluator and the classroom
teacher and were never entered into into
the record rendering the record
inaccurate I had an expert evaluator who
taught at Harvard Medical School and did
specialty residencies in Columbia who
was an expert in autism the school had
an evaluator who had an eight-month
Masters that she got at Rivier College
had no medical training was not a
specialist in autism and could not
understand the statistical relevance of
the outcomes of her own
testing because my witness was not
granted access to observe my son in
school more weight was placed on the
less qualified evaluator the situation
was frustrating to say the least there
were no proo the as far as attorneys go
there were no proor options available to
me as a disabled veteran I'm on a fixed
income but I still had to pay thousands
and thousands of dollars which were
nothing to the district many districts
carry primx liability insurance which
covers their due process expenses and
they don't have to pay anything and
while my costs were equivalent to the
price of a small automobile what the
district spent was not even a rounding
error in their budget disadvantaged
groups like some others income
families minorities and English as a
second language Learners have no real
claim as a result of lack of viable educ
our DEA says we must act in the best
interest of the child at all times that
includes the school is that happening if
these children are being left unable to
care for them themselves once they leave
school because the school controlled the
information had unlimited funds and did
not have to prove
the de sacked against me and that was
only the beginning of the problems my
child is high functioning autistic
because of this the school feels that my
child is less deserving of help the
school district in their brief stated
that they were only required to give a
bare minimum benefit this is the rally
standard which has long been overturned
by the inur F standard um from the
Supreme Court furthermore the district
failed to provide progress reports or
provide all the services and alter
different aspects of service delivery to
minimize the the cost therefore
diminishing the effectiveness of the
service Services now in grade 11 my
child can only write on a fifth grade
level cannot Advocate and has difficulty
navigating remote learning and it has
lost almost two years of instruction
which will impact both higher education
which is no longer a
possibility this will Al also limit
employment options as a junior my
child's counselor helping figure out
what my child can do after school but
school has given up on him and devalues
existence in the world my child will not
be able to attain gainful employment or
live independently despite the fact that
he has an IQ of 160 children with IEPs
make up roughly 20% of Any Given
graduating class but they don't have the
same access to the curriculum as they're
non- disabled peers this becomes very
clear when you look at the proficiency
data for children with IEP Statewide
only 14% are proficient in math and 17%
are proficient in reading this leaves
very little chance for independent
living or self-sufficiency if we as a
the state continue to allow such a large
portion of our graduating high school
classes to be unemployable it's
unsustainable to keep our state solvent
the state will spend Millions supporting
kids who with the proper training and
services could have been independent
taxpaying members of our society it's
also unfair to kids many low-income kids
join the Army that's Ryan um need to
speak to the bill um and I think you're
starting to lose some of the folks here
just uh moving very quickly and trying
to get a lot done and we're we're we're
not really addressing specific language
within this bill which we need to have
you address thank
as the school
districts left to their own devices will
favor educational options that enable
them to conserve resources um many
school districts deny a few thousand
worth of services off of making this
decision on the basis of staff and
funding and not on what the child needs
in my case the district was denying
$7,000 worth of services over four years
which was less than the amount of
funding that they received from the
federal government and if you actually
look at the court case um deal which is
also cited um and will be in my written
testimony the school district spent $2
million in legal fees um over a few
thousand dollars of services as well um
Ida encourages collaboration and
creative thinking between the parent and
the school district to attain solutions
that will benefit the child to try and
reach some level of bance Ida discarded
or disallows schools bringing an
attorney to meeting un the parent brings
one first but this is not the reality as
districts have begun bringing in lawyers
before the IEP team meeting has ever
occurred um Justice Ginsburg noted that
if a school district not have the burden
of proof the district is unlikely to
reach a consensus with the parent about
an
IEP the decision on the schaer v's case
was attained because the parent state
Maryland did not have a state law
regarding who should um have the burden
of proof Pro the default position was
that the person bringing the action
should have that Duty therefore there
are some states which have that law in
place um Alaska Alabama Connecticut DC
Delaware Georgia Illinois Kentucky
Minnesota West Virginia New York New
Jersey Delaware and Georgia we're we are
here today because we're asking for
children to become inde independent and
educated we want them to have aimful
employment and to be active participants
in society this law is not new and did
not negatively impact the number of due
processes filed um if anything these
states um experienced a decrease in due
process filings after this law was
passed part of the reason was if you
look at the Cadre website they um they
track these states and they look at
their D Miss Ryan I think you've gone
well beyond the time that you know
you're allocated you need to wrap this
please hearing officers are actually
trained by the school district attorneys
and have personal relationships with
them I don't believe any parent would
bring a frivolous lawsuit because it's
just such a nightmare and I think that
with the schools bringing a more
in-house special education they don't
take into consideration the needs of the
individual child um I support 581 I
think it's necessary and I ask that you
vote in favor of it thank
[Music]
you
have sorry when people raise their hand
and then put it down they move all over
the list yeah um
so
Tiffy
sorry how many total people do we have
that are going to be testifying on this
bu
uh Tiffany Capone I've just promoted you
there I'm here can you hear me yes we
can
Tiffany okay thank you for having me um
my name is Tiffany Capone um I
am I I am a parent of a child who has um
a disability who is an adult now and I
am also have worked in the special ed
setting as a special education teacher
and residential and private school and I
currently uh am working as an advocate
for parents and I I appreciate your time
and I don't want to take up much of it I
just wanted to speak on behalf of the
parents that I have worked with over the
many
years that I have been practicing in
special education and on their behalf um
I totally support um HB 581 based on my
experiences in and out of uh the public
school setting I've had wonderful
experiences working with some very
dedicated administrators and Educators
but I have a unique position where I
have been able to see also what happens
behind closed doors and it's not always
great like any session there are people
who are wonderful at their jobs and
dedicated and some that are not and this
unfortunately does often come out um as
you move up the line between parent and
schools with um some disagreements
and
unfortunately my experience with
parents there's not it's not fair for
them to be
expected to be able to to provide the
amount of information that's required
and the time that's needed to defend the
rights of their child that they're
already entitled to they're living their
lives as we are day in day out raising
children who may have disabilities they
are not employed full-time to be dealing
with this they may also already have a
full-time job outside of their home the
school districts employ people to do
this they are the experts they are the
ones that the hearing officers look to
for expert testimony they are the ones
who oftentimes will tell parents while
we're sitting across the table that they
know more than the parent
does after an enormous amount of time of
going back and forth lengthy periods
time lots of hours and still not being
able to come to the conclusion that
works for the child and that the child
is entitled to you have different
options and when you work through all of
those and come to doe process you've
already spent a lot of money as a parent
and many parents
don't have children thinking they're
going to need a fund of 30 to $50,000
set aside in their budget to be able to
defend the rights of their child to get
a free and public education um school
districts already have this money set
aside they have lawyers on staff who are
already doing this and I I think there's
a misconception that if a school were to
lose which they often don't um due to
the enormous amount of resources they
have um they often it seems to me that
people have
this perception that the school is
taking funds
from uh um areas that affect students
this isn't the case and I'm not going to
take up everyone's time trying to
explain where this money comes from it's
budgeted there's insurance if the
district loses it comes from that if the
parent loses it's coming from their
paycheck and it's a lot of money
um I have seen years go by where there's
no progress and parents are still paying
to try and get what we all want for our
children
um like I said I I appreciate time I
don't want to take a lot of it up I just
would like to support all the parents
and all the students who really need to
be heard and hope that you'll vote in
favor of HB
581 thank you very much there any
questions for Tiffany from the
committee not seeing any hands thank you
very much thank you you're welcome next
we have
Kate Kate you've been promoted go
welcome to thank you very much I
appreciate the time committee chair and
members can you hear me okay yes you can
okay excellent all right well thank you
for this opportunity I do appreciate it
I will try to keep it short I'm here as
a New Hampshire Citizen and mother to
four children three of those children
have autism and other special needs I'm
also here as an unofficial volunteer
being a voice for other special needs
families I've heard countless stories of
parents simply needing a little support
for their children to no avail due to
this burdensome process such as the
power uh Power align tree worker who
trimmed the trees behind my house who
shared that his autistic eighth grader
could still not read because he had no
ability to afford or figure out the
unmanageable process our families in New
Hampshire as in many other states have
been dealing with many children with
legitimately diagnosed medical issues
that affect these children academically
behaviorally developmentally and
emotionally in the school environment
I'll say it again their medical
diagnosis U the need for special
education continues to grow and has
turned into a living nightmare for most
families in New Hampshire due to lack of
resources and other things but I can
tell you there's no such thing as a
frivolous case in all of my encounters
with the almost 2,000 parents from the
New Hampshire autism group and several
other groups that I helped manage out of
voler State just due to the need these
are families and children who are
allowed to quote unquote fly under the
radar and belong to families that try to
obtain help and quickly learn that they
cannot navigate the cumbersome and
difficult process these are families and
children who are largely from
financially disadvantaged situations
already having a child with special
needs is demanding and expensive and
there is not an option to not provide
this type of help so many of us find a
way to get get the help sacrificing our
health and well-being in the process to
survive the
journey I'm here today as a mother who
has lived the struggle so much so that
it tore our family apart and that
struggle began in Earnest when our
children set foot in schools this is not
to say that we've not been able to gain
common ground with the folks who have
gotten to know our family over the years
we now have kids in third fourth and
fifth grades after many years of
struggling we were able to get some help
some of that which is very good some a
work in progress but the path we
traveled is all too common leading to
Broken financially strapped families
struggling to hang on by their
proverbial fingernails when my now
severely ill child with an acquired
medical condition and autism was in
first grade he cried nightly while I
begged for help he was not able to have
anyone even check in with him while the
head of the PTA had had a one-on-one PA
up for her son due to anxiety my child
then went through a series of spiraling
downward
physically uh issues due to the massive
amount of stress he encountered the
following years with little to no help
he's now gotten some response but
without my ability to hire an attorney
having just gotten out of a six-year
complex divorce not of my choosing we
are not going to get very far can you
imagine being a parent going through
this with one child at once working
full-time dealing with the host of
issues that child has to address outside
of school and paying privately for
things to make up for the lack of
support what I'm here to say however is
for any of us involved it does not need
to be this painful and hard not for
anyone not for the school administration
which are usually stretched thin they
are people that are they teachers and
assistant principles they're playing
multiple roles and the system has an
opportunity for us to work better
together not using the legal system
which is based on a system of opposition
of one party to the other we're not
talking about suing a school district
necessarily we're talking about small
matters that can be worked out for the
most part as attorney Stevens mentioned
earlier this same evidence is provided
on both sides a huge difference however
is that parents might as well not even
try to present evidence or spend the
money to get help because they lost
before they even started most of us have
been told we cannot even go to mediation
unless we have an attorney this is a
common request from educational
Advocates as it stands today under idea
schools already only have to consider
medical diagnosis like autism not just
accept them and coupled with the way the
New Hampshire law is written now leaves
typically financially stretched and
lifeb burdened families with even more
hardship I speak not just for me but for
the many teachers and administrators who
can't say a word but they know things
need to change flipping the burden of
proof makes sense both from a stretched
educational system perspective and also
from a hardship to fam's perspective we
need to encourage a more collaborative
process these matter matters are not
frivolous or the same as a lawsuit in
any way these are generally matters of a
child needing a weekly speech or
occupational therapy session of 30
minutes child needing a little
paraprofessional support and that's
generally about all our neurodiverse
kids need a common set of help and
supports a set of things that's nearly
standard for all of them and none of
them should require fighting
individually the same battle over and
over and over these supports are very
basic and relate to providing a free and
appropriate education as justified by
legitimate medical diagnosis and
documentation often more than would ever
be required even in a court of law and
because of the burden of proof It's
never enough how would you feel being
denied a wheelchair if you couldn't walk
how would you feel if you were forced to
demonstrate you cannot walk because
somebody can't see it there is no
difference here please help our kids and
schools come together in a better way
let our families and schools work out a
better process we don't need to invest
this time of this kind of time and money
to fight over whether a child needs
basic supports and services let's invest
where it makes sense please approve and
support this Bill thank you thank you
very much are there any
questions sha K it's sha H can you can
you send a copy of your testimony to me
or to all of the happy to sorry I didn't
get it to you guys in advance thank
you thank
you thanks for hearing me I do have a
lobbyist yeah oppose thank you very much
Kate uh are there any further
questions thank you very much thank
you okay
um Becky Wilson from the uh School Board
Association okay we have Becky Wilson
from the school boards
Association
go ahead please Miss Wilson good
afternoon members of the committee
chairman lad thanks for hearing my
testimony today I will try to keep it
brief I know it's been a long day for
all of you uh I'm Becky Wilson I'm the
director of governmental relations for
the New Hampshire school boards
Association I come to you today uh we're
in opposition to House Bill 581 um and I
want to also just um share this
testimony with the background that I was
prior to moving into this position a
special ed director in New Hampshire for
20 years um and out of those 20 years
I've only gone through a full due
process hearing one time it is a rarity
um and I think that that speaks quite
honestly I I know there's been a lot of
testimony today about people's
challenges um with the team process and
the collaboration at the school level
but I will tell you that for most
districts collaborating with families is
at the priority level for all of these
um decisions and due process truly is a
last resort um in terms of resolving a
dispute that can't be resolved in other
ways um and that quite honestly uh there
are times within the law where we are
required to file a due process hearing
to resolve a dispute so I certainly
don't want it to sound as though um
people are on either side frivolously
filing for due process it's not
something that is as common I think as
uh what's been maybe portrayed today but
I do want to speak from the Schoolboard
perspective a bit um about the concerns
I think I shared this with you in some
written testimony already um there
certainly are obviously the fiscal
impacts of this bill were the burden of
proof to shift to the school district
all the time as some other people have
already testified there are times
already where the district shares has
the burden of proof because they are the
ones that filed for the due process
hearing so this does not necessarily
resolve it completely it's already
resolved for a lot of the time when
these file these are filed um but it
would shift the burden of proof and
persuasion to the district for any
reason that a due process were filed
regardless of who files for the due
process um certainly the legal fees and
things like that there are some
insurance um benefits that districts do
carry however the findings of the
hearing if those carry with it uh an
outof District placement perhaps um
additional Services those C are not
covered by insurance and those costs can
stay with the district for a very long
period of time it's rare that a case
would go to do process towards the end
of a child's School career quite
honestly in the last two or three years
most of these things are happening um at
a younger level and some of the um the
hearing findings or what's mandated to
the district as a result if they were to
um not win the hearing so to speak are
years of placements that then would
follow into the operating budget because
they would no longer be considered
unanticipated um so they couldn't use
that um fund that several people have
talked about in other conversations this
session of um unanticipated special ed
costs those can't be accessed once you
know that this cost is now to be
anticipated for a number of years those
costs are going to downshift to the
operating budget um and are going to
fall to the taxpayers so um that
certainly is a piece of the litig of the
fiscal impact secondly going to hearing
um is a lengthy procedure regardless of
whether you are the family or the
district if you are the district you are
taking a a high number of Staff quite
often out of the building out of the
classroom to prepare for a hearing to
you go it could go for two days it could
go for two months um and you are taking
staff out of the buildings and out from
the classroom of all the other students
that are um looking for that person's
instruction and those service providers
to be there for them the district is
incurring substitute costs as a result
um as well as um District staff needing
to be tied up so to speak um and lastly
I will just say um and I want to speak a
little bit to the I think there was a
comment made earlier about the human
cost of going to Due Process um and
having a case go to Due Process early on
in a child's School career um does erode
that relationship with that family quite
often between the family and the
district for a very long period of time
districts do not want to go to Due
Process hearings um there are many other
ways to resolve it there's neutral
conferences there are mediations there's
facilitated IEP meetings um shifting
this cost shifting this burden approv to
the district all the time I don't see
how that really um allows the parent
parents more financial ability to secure
um the support that has been brought up
Shifting the burden doesn't
necessarily somehow allow for more
resources to be diverted to the parent
unless there's a belief that by Shifting
the burden um more parents will prevail
in these cases and some of the findings
will be for the district to have to
reimburse for the cost of these parents
fees and outside evaluations Etc that's
the only way I that it makes sense to me
of how this shift in the burden would
somehow allow families to have uh more
ability to pursue due process hearings
so um I'm happy to take any questions
from the committee I apologize for going
over my time thank you Becky are there
association
yes I don't see any know I don't see any
hands okay thank thank you very much
thanks Becky
okay um next next we have Patricia Eno
um you signed up to speak for four
minutes I I think what I'm going to do
from this point onward because we still
have quite a few to speak I'm GNA limit
people to three minutes please thank
you okay go thank you to the can you
hear me yes we can okay thank you to
those who wrote this bill and brought it
up for hearing um please consider my
position as apparent victim of New
Hampshire's um special education due
process um I feel strongly that under
the current rules the burden of proof in
one of these hearings is absolutely
insurmountable to any
parent
um you might think that this is Shifting
the burden from the person who brought
the action to always the school but
there's very few defined cases where the
school has to um file for due process C
if there's
an um initial
evaluation to provide initial um
services to the child or if the school
does not wish to pay for an independent
educational evaluation only in those
cases does the school have the burden of
proof um please check the percentage of
due process hearings that are actually
brought by the parent versus the school
district um apparent will file because
the child's not making progress if the
parent were ever to win any type of
complaint the most concerning outcome
for the district is that they would be
compelled to do what they were supposed
to do in the first
place um regardless of the type of
complaint they could win quite a bit has
been said about mediation mediation is
absolutely optional for both parties and
it was refused by my school district
because they wanted to put the burden of
proof on me I'm not a public speaker and
the lawyer and the team of lawyers
behind
are
um those that oppose this bill claim you
have the whole team they must invite you
to meetings well yes they do but what
comes out of those meetings and gets
placed into the written IEP is at the
discretion of the special head
Department administrator take it or
leave
it
um there's also um if the district is
non-compliant client non-compliant in
providing Services agreed to by the
whole team but the IEP contains words or
phrases put in there by administrators
such as as needed or when required you
lose the school has experts that can
complain that can claim they didn't feel
it was needed or it turned out it wasn't
required up to X hours actually means
anywhere from zero to X hours and the
district is compant at zero parent files
the Department of Education recommends
against using these words and phrases
because they might be misinterpreted but
they don't prohibit it every word in an
IEP is reviewed by the district
administrator parent files for due
options if there's one thing a special
education administrator can do it's St
hold another meeting rescheduling the
meeting continuing it because of a
concern that the parent got got pushed
to the end of the meeting and time ran
out are requiring updated testing that
will take some time to complete we have
deadlines to file and um the school can
push us Beyond those deadlines I want to
um speak in on behalf of bill um 581 and
I appreciate you listening thank you
thank you thank you very much are there
any
questions thank you very
okay next we have Bonnie Dunham Bonnie
education thank you very much um I
wanted to make I think I'm unmuted now
thank you very much um I am very much in
support of this bill and I appreciate um
representative cordelli bringing it
Forward first it's important to know
that there are not very many due process
hearings in New Hampshire we've had an
average of 3 per year over the past 5
years and which means that most often
parents in schools work their issues out
before they get to a due process hearing
um and and New Hampshire does have a lot
of options that go beyond even those
required by the federal law for that to
happen but when a parent does decide
that they need to file a due process
hearing it's because they they really
believe that's the only option for them
to receive the services that their child
needs something has gone wrong they've
they've seen their child fail um and
they just reach the point where nothing
else will work and as someone already
mentioned some of the other options the
alternative dispute resolution options
are voluntary and so if the school
doesn't want to go the parent is left
with very few choices
um we when we have those few due process
hearings per year parents rarely win
it's an it's an imbalanced situation in
the past five years parents have won
about 10% of those due process hearings
um and so it certainly does discourage
people from using that process um
because of those low numbers and and so
it's a real challenge for families
there's an inherence imbalance in that
process because sorry because when the
evidence is presented by the both
parties first you only burden of proof
only comes up if it's if it's close if
the person can't determine clearly which
person has made their case and so it's
not even an issue that comes up very
often but when it does it makes sense
that it be the school district that
carries that burden of proof um even the
Supreme Court while they ruled in favor
of of the party that has filed for the
hearing having the burden approved they
recognize that schools have a natural
advantage in that process um and so what
and some of that natural Advantage comes
because schools have more experience
they know the special ed law they have
experience with the procedures they have
access to more resources including the
teachers evaluators and specialed
education experts and they have control
over the witnesses many of the witnesses
work for them it's really hard to
testify in opposition to your employer
um and so that that um can make for a
difficult
situation and schools are better
prepared to carry the burden of proof
when a school district develops a
proposal to a school to a parent for
example a draft IEP or a proposed IEP
they're supposed to have the the data
the information that supports that
proposal that that can convince the
parent that here's why this is going to
provide your child with a free
appropriate public education so if they
do end up going to a hearing the school
district has already done their work
they have the information that they
case okay thank
you minut
Bonnie are there any questions uh
represent LE you have a question I do
thank you Mr chairman just very I just
wanted to make sure I heard right uh
Miss Dunham you were saying that there's
approximately three cases filed per year
of late is that it that it's there are
approximately three that are held
sometimes people resolve prior or they
withdraw okay uh just a brief followup
Mr chair um and are some of those cases
do they I think someone who testified
previously said there are cases where
the school actually files so would those
do do your numbers include those cases
yes it was about 5050 it was um there
were 16 and there were there were seven
filed by parents seven filed by the
school district and to that it really
wasn't clear reading the report who
filed I see okay thank you you're
welcome you have a question yeah thank
you repres just at the beginning of your
presentation I I didn't catch I must
have missed it what who you represent or
what your what Your I'm a parent of a
child with disabilities and fortunately
we were always able to work with our
school to get what our son needed um but
because of my professional job and my
connections to many support groups I
speak to a lot of parents and I know
this is a huge concern I also serve on
the state advisory committee for special
education but I am not representing any
of those groups I'm representing myself
okay thank you I just appreciate the
really thorough
presentation thank you very much uh
Bonnie I do have a question for you
you've worked with groups with us many
many times over the years here uh to try
to improve specialed ucation and
services to Charter Schools Etc um I
have a question if a parent sitting in
an IEP meeting and I've been through
this as an administrator principal and
teacher and the parent says I can't
agree with that um and and an
administrator writes in something such
as as needed um that we've heard spoken
to earlier this afternoon what recourse
does that parent have if they don't sign
what happens first they could say you've
given me a lot to think about why don't
we have another meeting so that we can
talk about this more after we've both
digested the information we've each
presented they can ask for a facilitated
IEP team meeting they have uh thirdparty
moderated discussions they have
facilitated IEP team meetings they can
ask the school to go to mediation um or
they may be able to go out and get more
information themselves to make their
case to the school district at another
IEP team meeting why this child needs
this why what you're proposing will not
work um
if ultimately they are not able to reach
agreement then the parent either settles
for what they believe isn't appropriate
for their child is less than or they
file for a due process hearing thank you
very much thank you are there any
further questions for Miss
Don thank you Bonnie thank you next I
was looking for Darlene Mand m n DH I
don't see her in the drop down so we
have four hands raised uh first we will
go with Joe
hananon uh I'm promoting you to panelist
education hello can you hear me yes we
can sorry I was just dropped and just
got back on uh hi um my name is Joe
Hannon I'm a former State Rep and I'm
the parent of a six-year-old a sixth
grader with uh who has diagnosis of down
syndrome uh my wife has been actively
involved in the Down Syndrome community
and different activist groups but uh
she's unable to be here today because of
work uh earlier there was mentioned of
the the the ideas of innocence and
burden and I'd like to say that first of
all every child is innocent and the
burden to provide a free and appropriate
education is on the state and the school
districts uh and a little background
about my daughter I am very fortunate
that my wife and I were both doctors we
have a lot of resources to provide for
our children the best that we can uh we
only had one dispute with our uh uh
school with uh in regards to my
daughter's IEP and that was early on
they wanted her to have uh part of her
activities were uh to enhance core
strength so they had pole dancing as one
of her requirements and I was the only
male in the room and I said well it's
probably not a good idea so they quickly
dropped it no court cases it was all fun
and and well and good but um anyway uh a
lot of parents aren't aren't able to
access the same level of professional
legal expertise the school districts
have access to and that's a major factor
and a major issue as to why um they they
don't go forward with some of these
cases uh whether it's the real or
perceived costs of attorney
representation and whether they can
actually overcome these burdens of
winning against the state we heard uh
someone just say that about 10% of the P
people win these cases when they go to
that level uh in some states like
Maryland which has been discussed
significantly earlier about 15% of the
cases brought are won by the parents and
a lot of States uh that have the same
burden on the the plane the person
bringing the charge are are very
similar um you know one of the big
reasons uh you know the lobbyist earlier
who mind you you know all these parents
and people coming today are mostly
unpaid people but the people trying to
stop this actually have the money to
bring a paid lobbyist in and that person
said that a lot of these cases actually
occur early on in the education of the
child um well that's actually a good
thing because if something is determined
early that a child needs they have many
more years to benefit from that service
and ultimately if you can address these
needs earlier we can save not just the
child a lot of Anguish and improve their
lives but we can save society as a whole
the taxpayer in general from the burdens
of having to provide for some of these
individuals later in life because
they've had a better education at an
early time so in conclusion I'd like to
just say 30 seconds left is great
returning the burden approv to the
school districts does not unduly burden
the districts or the taxpayers and it's
going to ensure the tax dollars are
being spent on effective programs and
enhances District accountability I'd be
happy to take any questions thank you
thank you very much uh honorable Hannah
um are there any questions for
Joe not seeing any thank you very much
thank you you're welcome next we have
Moren Tracy Moren I'm promoting you to
education
yourself there you go there we go hello
everyone thank you um so good afternoon
chairman lad and members of the
education committee my name is maren
Tracy and I've been a resident of merac
New Hampshire for about 30 years I have
four grown children in their early 20s
one of my children experiences a rear
disability called prayor syndrome which
was diagnosed at Birth uh it's kind of
like autism plus food um I'm asking that
you support House Bill 581 I have been
in education for over 25 years teaching
in private private schools as well as
public elementary secondary as well as
higher education I worked for the
University of New Hampshire in
collaboration with the Bureau of special
education as an educational consultant
for many school districts in New
Hampshire uh we worked with grants and
what we did is um the project was to
help schools become more proactive
instead of reactive this is called
multi-tiered systems of supports uh this
work included system building uh for
academics behavior and to produce fiscal
Improvement both short and long term
previously for 10 years I served on the
special education State advisory
committee and I'm back again right now
uh I've earned a master's degree in
education and I am currently enrolled in
a jurist Doctrine program although I
have had extensive training in the
educational field the road through
special education was difficult with my
family and my daughter despite my gra
background and having a good school
district to work with we had many
challenges in our educational experience
one of the big ones starting with the
school trying to suspend my daughter
from the upper elementary school because
of behavior difficulties which behavior
is part of her
diagnosis the IEP team had decided to to
have her attend a private school and I
was in agreement I was I I always say
this is my first time ever having a
however old child with a disability I
had no experience before um the IEP team
decided to have her attend this private
school I was in agreement until she was
restrained and put into a seclusion room
on a daily basis I did not realize that
restraints and seclusion was a customary
practice despite being an educator after
finding br on my daughter I pulled her
out of that private school however the
public school did not let her come back
the school said she was too dangerous
for the public school now since she had
been restrained suddenly after seven
years of public school she was too
dangerous I filed a complaint with the
New Hampshire Department of Education it
was only through the help of the parent
information center specifically Bonnie
that I had any idea on even how to do
this again despite being an educator I
had documented mented everything so the
results of the complaint were in my
favor and they ordered the school to
have my child return to public school
and for the district to have training in
her rare syrum the pain and tears that I
experienced are what continue to fuel my
desire to help others due to my unique
background I have worked in well over 50
schools here in New Hampshire I know
what happens in schools mostly it's a
systemic problem not a person problem
School typically work in a reactive
State and it's hard to be more proactive
especially in special education however
I will be honest there are some
districts that have administrators who
engage in bullying and retaliation to
whether it be other employees or
families you can spot this when you see
that the the person never mentions the
child's name throughout a whole meeting
it becomes about adult problems and not
children problems parents do not have a
fair shot in the special education due
process procedures it is expensive
emotional and it is unfair to have the
burden of proof lie in their laps the
school districts with the taxpayers
money hire attorneys to represent them
not the student despite the committee's
well-educated background without
expensive representation arue I would
argue that anybody on this committee
would be able to win a special education
due process hearing the schools have
expertise they have the money and they
have the tenacity currently the I'm
sorry your time is up you want to close
a sentence or that was my last line
currently the special education due
process burden prooof is imbalanced and
this bill is the right thing to do for
New Hampshire families thank you for
your service and for your time thank you
very much Mar thank you very much for
your testimony are there any questions
for
marine not see any thank you very
much
cruso how are you
there yeah somebody should tell them
Mark Mr Caruso are you able to hear
um we'll go to um Alicia Houston
promoting you and we'll go back to Mr
cruso if there's time yeah go ahead
the
is
no they uh they had they were not on the
me hello hell go ahead please oh okay
sorry um so I want to start um with
hello representatives and thank you for
allowing me to speak I am a proud New
Hampshire resident and a parent uh in
our amazing Granite State as a mother of
two children both which have learning
setbacks and require special education
assistance I am testifying today in
support of House Bill
581 I have to share that as a special
education parent the current process is
broken when relative to the burden of
proof being held on the parent as a
mother and constituent the process of
advocating for my children has and will
continue to be a full-time role to which
I am not compensated nor do I expect to
be we need to shift the burden of proof
to help families throughout New
Hampshire to hold districts accountable
to federal and state laws in Nashville
alone we currently have a number of
state and federal complaints to the
offices of civil rights in conjunction
with countless
individual education plans Amendment
meetings and we also have had to VI
compensatory service requests for
refusal of services House Bill 581 would
not only help the financial constraints
for families which often do not have the
financial backing to fight their
help avoid significant financial
setbacks for the students for the
schools to begin at the ground level
with proper construction and formatting
of their admin Administration for
special
education I spend the majority of my
time advocating for my children's
educational means which are protect
which are protected by a number of
federal laws Ida fape the Rehabilitation
Act of 1973 and likely others to
repetitively remind and fight the
education department here in my resident
town of nashille
on these federal laws I spend countless
hours to review rsas and federal
statutes in order to have the vernacular
to use these special education meetings
as a platform to ensure that I'm
consistently and effectively
communicating the needs of my children
in complete transparency I have to be
honest with you that one of the most
significant
changes or eye-opening experiences for
me has been the fact that I had to face
as a result of covid-19 to run quick
study IDE ideologies on the rules and
regulations as well as federal and state
laws again in order to advocate for my
children's needs in 11 months many
parents in my district alone have have
faced a direct refusal of services in
combination with a special education
depart Department who went so far as to
implement strategies to deny and refuse
services to many special education
students I would like to
end with another statement of gratitude
I encourage you to look into the
positives of this bill and hold special
educ departments to forcibly discontinue
unlawful practices by way of Shifting
the burden of
proof hold on I'm so sorry the only way
to do this is to help our children and
families who do not have access to
unlimited funding and to shift the
burden of proof in order to force them
to review their processes and compliance
so in conclusion I implore you all to
vote Yes on House Bill 581 to shift the
burden of proof which would ideally
enforce these districts to create
policies at the bottom in order to avoid
potential risk outcomes through
litigation due process and mediation
expenses thank you so much I am
available for any
questions thank you very much Miss
Houston are there any questions
s not seeing any hands thank you very
much
Alicia okay uh we're going to try uh
whoops Mr bro what left okay okay um
Heather
Young hello hi there hi thank
you um thank you representative lad and
members of the committee um my name is
Heather young I live in Rochester um I
apologize I'm just getting in from from
work so this is Lucas um and I did
submit some written testimony this
morning so I won't read everything all
over again um I just wanted to reiterate
the importance of supporting a bill like
this um Lucas is in fifth grade um he
does receive special education services
we're a family who's very fortunate to
be connected to many resources in the
state including the parent information
center and all of the trainings that
they've been able to provide for us um
if it wasn't for some of that I'm not
sure where we would be uh we do um we do
think that we're a family that's well
connected and we still struggled really
hard with our school district um despite
the rules and laws in place that are
there to support us uh we still continue
to um have an issue with being able to
prove that the services that were being
provided were not adequate uh despite
those rules helping to support that um
the district does have an indispensable
amount of money to bring attorneys or
non attorney special Ed Consultants to
the table um to fight against families
that unfortunately happened in our
situation for more than a year and we um
unfortunately could no longer continue
to fight that battle um one for
resources and two for for what it was
doing to our family and our child um our
child was getting injured at school um
if a bill like this were in place to
begin with um we would be able to to
know that we could continue forward with
the amount of energy that it would take
and our son wouldn't have have to be in
a private school right now um we're very
fortunate for the school that he is in
he is a valued member of that school but
unfortunately he's not with his his
local peers um that he and community
that he's grown up with for the last um
eight years of his education so we do uh
this is a desperate need um among other
things to help our education um for
students who receive special education
uh this is definitely a step to to help
with that um and I ask that you do
support this and uh full testimony has
been submitted this morning uh to the
committee so thank you for your time
thank you very much for taking the time
to testify Heather are there any
questions of
Heather once again thank you very much
for coming today thank you you're
welcome
okay yeah last lastly we have uh will
peruso welcome to education sorry about
the mixup before hi can you hear me now
yes yes we can oh great thank you uh so
my son is a uh beautiful eight-year-old
um nonverbal autistic child he's been in
the school district for just over four
years uh I've spent upwards of $20,000
trying to help motivate his education to
be on the right track uh that doesn't
seem to help unfortunately my budget
doesn't renew itself every year like the
school districts does so in order for me
to use those res ources that I could be
using to enhance his life in other ways
I'm using it to fight against the school
district to me the words free and
appropriate education has yet to apply
to anything I've done or has been done
about his education if you break down
those words
individually um it's certainly not free
and his education certainly isn't
appropriate um so um over the course of
four years I've collected a notebook of
pictures and photos of bruises and
injuries that is it's very difficult to
hold the school accountable for
these injuries um that causes long-term
emotional damage to him in fact going to
school is a problem as is it uh being a
mile from the school he starts to cry
and grind his teeth uh causes lots of
emotional stress um so the school has
seemed to provide the lowest form of
education for him which in turn keeps
him
disabled um we they don't Supply highly
trained staff to implement the
appropriate
education um parents who are educated
and pay attention and are involved are
often
um kind of deated to their character to
the team and school often retaliates
causing more issues isues um there's no
accountability who's watching over the
school district is it just the parents
that file complaints is that how how
they keep the schools accountable um
during the remote learning process was
uh we got a really eye openening
experience of just how abusive his
education is everything from the
implementing to the schedule changes to
just people not communicating on the
team this has been from one end the
other
and so this has been happening in front
of our eyes we can only imagine what
happens when we can't see what's going
on um
so um being in there for four years he
doesn't even know the alphabet yet he he
can't he can't do much and so all the
data that you collect and people talk
about the data that's only as good as
the people collecting it um we've often
found lots of issues with the data
collection being inaccurate and taking
in properly and it makes things look
good but in real life the reality is
he's he's not gaining a lot so I'm in
support of this bill
581 and uh thank you for your time thank
you very much Mr peruso are there any
questions for Mr
pero thank you very much will thank
you okay we have one more speaker uh
Jen
oops this will be the last we not going
to allow any more speakers raising hands
like that that's what we've gone on here
for a while okay hello hello hi there
welcome hi this hi this is Jennifer blri
of um hopkington New Hampshire I
submitted written testimony this morning
um I apologize in advance if you hear
any of my four kids in the
background um so I just wanted to um
voice my support for HB 581 in my own
personal capacity as a citizen um I do
have two children with d dyslexia who
receive special education I also have
consider considerable experience working
in the public schools with children with
various disabilities that received
special ad as a physical therapist um
I'm a decoding dyslexia New Hampshire
member I'm transitioning to a leadership
role in that um group and I am a parent
representative on the sack committee um
and again I speaking in my own personal
capacity not with regards to any of
those groups or jobs um I do W to I
won't read you know read through my
whole written testimony testimony I hope
you guys can look at it um but I do want
to say that if a parent does have ample
time money and
resources um and the ability to handle
the stress of um
advocating for their
child then they likely will be able to
Bear the burden of proof s
successfully um possibly file for due
process settle at
mediation um and not even have to go the
due process route um and in order to
prepare to um prepare to go to doe
process um a parent really has to be on
top of things from the beginning um
which not all parents even realize that
they need to um do so it's you know
keeping track of emails keeping track of
various things um periodically possibly
getting private evaluations just to
check it you know just to get a second
opinion on how your child is doing so
there's a lot that parents can do if
they have
resources um to even you know even
prevent ever having to um file you
process a common phrase that I have
heard is the best way to prevent or to
prevent due process is to prepare for
due process so I just wanted to give you
guys that perspective that if parents
have you know again they have those
resources then you know they'll probably
be okay um and I'm not concerned about
those parents I'm concerned about the
millions of parents you know in the
state that have children with
disabilities that are not able to
research special education laws you know
they might even not even know there are
federal laws in place and state laws in
place um and and are not able to be on
top of everything in the beginning um
I'm concerned about those parents who
you know it might be after one you know
a bunch of things have gone wrong that
they start researching this stuff and
have to go down this path of filing for
due process and they may not be able to
afford um private evaluations that can
cost thousands of dollars and then on
top of those private evaluations they
would need to pick a private evaluator
that could come to a due process hearing
so that might not mean going to the best
hospitals in Boston that might mean
getting a very well-respected private
evaluator that you could actually pay to
come to a due process hearing so it's
just a really really complicated process
and it is at this time I feel you know
strongly stacked against parents that do
not have the resources and this bill you
know I don't think it will all of those
problems there'll still be parents that
can you know afford expert Witnesses and
and all of that stuff but there but for
the parents that can't afford that this
this should help them a little bit the
the schools have the resources they have
the specialists in the schools um they
have the people to do the
evaluations you know they sometimes it's
just a matter of picking the correct
evaluation for the student um so picking
the most appropriate evaluations for a
child with dyslexia as opposed to you
know you know picking things that um
aren't always consider the the um most
appropriate for kids with dyslexia so
anyway I just think that this bill is
really important for those parents that
are disadvantaged and I support HB 581
and I encourage you guys to read my
written testimony and um really really
strongly consider supporting this um to
help make sure all students in New
Hampshire have access to a free and
appropriate public
education thank you much J are
there see any hands thank you very much
okay okay thank
the 71 support 30 opposed and 14 test 14
you so this concludes our hearing on
82581 this hearing is closed and this
concludes our hearings and work for
today uh this meeting is adjourned thank
you for participating everybody out
there in the field and in this room as
well see you Thursday are there any
questions I still don't have an
understanding of our stes where meeting
yet I got to make the call right now
aren't we meeting Thursday oh yeah we
are talk about the following week okay
just make so thank you very much bye
everybody bye bye
all